[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey you guys it's wednesday party time
sorta well it'll be party time like
after we've had a few more drinks and
gotten all into it partying on a
wednesday
any day is a good day for a party gotta
get myself revved up for this yeah come
on you can do it yeah get with it i know
so look steve steven seagal is like
snarling at you from your shirt
yeah
he's looking very stern isn't he
[Laughter]
so what's going on with everybody
let's see who's in dj maniac says uh
about the psycho gourmand review the
girl in that was the best part in my
opinion yeah it's like i don't usually
like um that whole sassy kid type of
[ __ ] but she was like actually really
funny like i really liked her esther
said uh i saw the trailer for last night
in soho on the imdb app it looks great
and i will be watching yeah that
actually we saw at the theater when we
went to see candyman and i was like wow
that looks like super weird and looks
like something i'd be like super antio
yeah we went ahead and got our amc um
[ __ ] stubs memberships a-list
memberships again yeah because this
saturday i want to go see
malignant the new james juan movie i've
been i think i've been calling it
malevolent but it's not it's malignant
this uh
gonna have to run this damn movie
marathon again
tell you what that we were on that for
about what one year two years yeah it
was a while it started to get to me
after a while to go to go into the
theater three times a week
um i mean you don't have to i mean it's
the nice thing about it is that reviews
at the time i know but it's like now
that we've expanded out and we now we
can watch reviews on we can do like
streaming services and stuff you don't
have to as long honestly the [ __ ] is so
cheap that as long as you go to like two
movies a month
two or three movies a month it's still
worth it you're still saving money yeah
there were a couple months though where
the the movies were pretty [ __ ] bad
well that's what i'm saying but you
don't have to like feel obligated to go
to three because i don't think we have
time to let go of three every week i
think i think on some of those bad
months there was maybe only for that
whole month maybe only one or two movies
that were kind of like memorable
yeah there are some months that are just
[ __ ] terrible yes it was back then i
think it's a good time to get into it
now because like i said it's september
and october that's the lead up to
halloween so it's like might be a lot of
like horror movies coming out
um you know which i'm always very
excited about
and you know if i could sneak booze in
there
uh who says you can't
you can't especially during the day yeah
no one's gonna they're gonna notice as
long as you're not too hammered coming
out it's like hey what's up
coming out of the movie
staff during the matinees staff doesn't
even give a [ __ ] they don't even notice
you that's what i'm saying i don't know
they don't care what they get like
minimum wage they're probably like
whatever do what you want you don't give
a [ __ ] as long as you don't like throw
up and we have to clean it up especially
you know me being at my age they're like
whatever you want to do sir because uh
you guessed it right there
[Laughter]
i mean they do have a bar in there but
it's really overpriced
we have gotten drinks there before yeah
they're overpriced and real weak yeah
but i mean sometimes it's fun i i do
like that they have like the themed
drinks yeah like to go with the movies i
think that's kind of cute yeah one of
those zombie movies remember they had a
green one
yeah yeah like a it was good we had it
yeah
i yeah i remember having a couple liking
them but they're not they're not super
strong but like i said it might just be
because they don't want like a bunch of
drunk [ __ ] like running around like
yahoos and they're like barfing on
everything and yeah falling over and
[ __ ] yeah that'll lower the prices of
those [ __ ] drinks and just [ __ ]
sell it like it's a bar
they have that that what they have those
restaurants that are like that now are
you dying in there
the theater you can die yeah yeah yeah
what's that [ __ ] called well they've
been there to see has it oh yeah yeah i
forgot what it's called though yeah they
have like their special just because
like i said they've had ones like that
for forever because i know that there's
um
what's that what's that kind of famous
one that's uh alamo drafthouse yeah
that's a movie theater and they have
like pretty much and we've been to like
in orlando we have the enzian
which is an independent i think they
only show one or two movies at a time
and it's usually like indie movies or
documentaries or foreign movies and
stuff but they have like a whole cafe
[ __ ] in there yeah that's not like going
to a movie theater though no it's not
like a movie theater it's more like
going to a cafe and watching like on a
big screen and i think they just have
beer and wine did they just have beer
and wine i remember going there and
seeing that that nick cave documentary
like around my birthday i just got one
but they might have cocktails i'm not
really sure because i know how expensive
it is around here to get a [ __ ]
liquor license
you know yeah seeing who's in there
david june i've been day drinking so i
apologize in advance uh oh you might
have to get put time out a few times
sandra's not in
esther said my high school drama teacher
would bring a flask to school and movie
theaters
there you go that's what we need a flask
as long as someone wanted small enough
to like fit in my purse i used to have
one i don't know what happened to it
whatever happened to my flask i don't
know i saw a dude [ __ ] go in there
with with somebody eat a whole meal
sitting there and then left the [ __ ] in
the [ __ ]
seat next to him
i mean if you're gonna do that at least
clean up after yourself for christ's
sake
i can't even stand like the people that
go in there and just buy popcorn and a
drink and it's like they can't they
don't have the decency to like throw it
in the garbage can even though it's on
the [ __ ] way out the door yeah holy
crap about these [ __ ] how
[ __ ] lazy can you be
it's like yes they have people to clean
that up but it's like that doesn't mean
that you can go around being a [ __ ]
filthy [ __ ] all the time goddamn
let's be an adult that's the thinking be
an adult and like i said it's not even
like you have to go out of your way
to throw the [ __ ] out i mean it's
literally on the way out the door you
have to go that way anyway so
throw your [ __ ] away so what do you got
what do you guys want the topic to be
today
nothing
i was thinking about aliens today i was
thinking about aliens last night
what brought that on because of all the
sci-fi movies we were doing we did like
fire in the sky and stuff and i was just
looking out the [ __ ] back window
there was waiting for the ufos to show
up they never did show up we were
remembering i think you told this story
before about that one
that one night when you was it the
middle of the night i feel like it was
one o'clock in the morning or somewhere
rather
and you woke me up like super excited
you're like look at this there's this
thing outside there's this thing outside
and i'm just like what who cares what it
is i'm sleepy and i was like is the
house burning down no then leave me
alone it's a high-tech police helicopter
and he he's like running he literally
ran out in the backyard naked yeah i hit
socks off
[Laughter]
he literally read look at it nobody else
look at it look at that [ __ ] thing
it had some kind of digital display on
it
you know what i mean i i didn't know
that they were doing that with the
helicopters now
it had like some kind of digital display
moving on it yeah red
you know red stuff you know
i'm from a time when helicopters look
boring there's a red light and a blue
light and some white lights
a red light a green light and some
[ __ ] white lights this thing had a
whole
display on it
i guess it was a [ __ ] police
helicopter had a what got my attention
was that the whole backyard lit up
because it yeah it hit it with a
spotlight
but then it moved on and it was using
the spotlight it was shining on
something
he was looking at a mile looking for you
tom he was he was waiting for you to run
out the sliding glass door or just naked
which i don't give a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
come on down aliens
[Laughter]
let's have sex
want to have sex with me come on
dj maniacs is naked with socks you're a
goddamn weirdo yeah
yeah
what was that it was a grass outside i
put socks on [ __ ] right out there he
just put socks on but no pants
no time for that there was no [ __ ]
time for that
there was no
oh my god
i just remember well i was like really
pissed off because i don't i do not like
being woke up for any because my you
know i don't sleep very well so it's
like i kind of treasure my sleep so it's
like somebody's like waking me up in the
middle of the night
just because you think it's an alien and
i looked at it and i was like dude
that's a helicopter jesus christ
i was like you got me out of bed for
this
even if it was aliens that'd still have
been bad
yeah no aliens worth me losing sleepover
tammy's laughing that i said i had socks
yeah
oh my god yeah
this [ __ ] was sexy man
yeah tom's little white butt cause i was
like out of the [ __ ] whole body was
white
[Laughter]
well i feel like people's butts are
early i'm not a [ __ ] waiter i'm not
worried about it like i said there's not
a lot of i mean
around here we have neighbors obviously
but most of them aren't in the backyard
yeah at one o'clock in the morning no
most of them are sleeping like it was
dark there's no lights out there
yeah we don't there's no lights around
the back yeah the lights are all up
front
mike barrett says talk giallo films or
murders in florida yeah we could do that
too um
i kind of i don't know if i'm gonna do
this yet so don't get too excited i mean
maybe i'll do it but i was kind of i
might have mentioned this before but for
october i wanted to do
um
maybe 31 days of horror so i do like 31
extra like movie reviews like one every
day
so i wanted to throw some like jello
movies in there so one of the one i
wanted to do um
what do you call it all the colors of
the dark because i really really like
that one or i remember really liking
that one the first time i watched it
summer was like kind of weird and like
psychedelic and [ __ ]
so i wanted to like review that one as
well
but
i kind of you know i i mostly i want to
do ones that have been on my list
forever that i can't believe i haven't
done yet and you know
and then i really want to get around to
so i don't know we'll we'll see i made a
little card for it today and i was just
like well i guess i can just do a couple
extra ones every week
tammy says my husband has been outside
in his underwear and work boots with his
gun looking for a bear
[Laughter]
i guess it's normal to me i mean that's
we would be sleeping out in the field in
the army and [ __ ] like that and you
might [ __ ] have to just jump out in
any state of dress
jump out of a [ __ ] you know i made a
[ __ ]
uh a sleeping bag or something and just
grab a weapon and start [ __ ] you know
prov pull up security in an emergency or
help in something it was all males we
were all male units nobody really gave a
[ __ ] but it didn't mean they'd be
running around in your underwear
not really
it's just i don't know i don't know it
was just very funny to me that yeah that
you just put on socks and nothing else
and then i was in a hurry look look
i didn't go that far
she's acting like i went up the street
right now it was just right about
[ __ ] 40 50 feet looking up
40 feet out the back door looking up at
this thing trying to figure out what it
was i can then i came back in
and then i said if that [ __ ] was a ufo
it was a helicopter right that [ __ ] was
not a ufo if that [ __ ] was a ufo i was
definitely gonna
see it you know what i mean and you're
definitely gonna get beamed up in there
i don't give a [ __ ]
and you were already naked so you were
like
right for probing they're aliens they
don't give a [ __ ] they don't have it
they don't have it don't encourage them
like that they don't have a concept of
naked aliens are above that
they just see you as an alien creature
like what when you see a bear you say
that bear's naked no it's just a bear
sometimes i do it depends
yeah
you see i see a cat he goes that cat
i've seen some animals that i said that
animal needs some clothes
[Laughter]
beige needed some clothes when we shaved
her
oh
we gave bishop did i ever share that
video years back it was a few years ago
we had we gave her the little the lion
cut we spent like almost 80 bucks to get
the [ __ ] cat a lion cut because it
was so [ __ ] well it was hot it was
summer time and she's very very very
fluffy
a mane and she had a long tail with a
ball on the end of it
and uh just uh
like little socks little socks little
socks
she was totally shaved
and she was she seemed like she was
embarrassed
when she came
home she was kind of like well it
probably didn't help that we were like
filming her and like laughing
i said i told her i was like we're not
laughing at you it's just it's super
cute she did look naked though she did
yeah but it was super cute i liked it
because they kept like her big fuzzy
head like this you know all the her fur
was here and i loved my the best part
was that they put a tiny pink bow yes in
a butter head which normally she if you
try to put anything on her she flips out
yeah like we try to put a harness on her
one time she liked it and she was and
she tried to crawl out from underneath
it i think she liked that it was cool
yeah but you could definitely tell that
she thought it was weird yeah i think
she was a little bit embarrassed like
she was kind of walking around i was
going what the [ __ ] and then like we
were trying to film her and she kept
like walking off like squishing her tail
like no i don't like it
she's like suddenly all this breeze is
coming in weird directions funny poor
beijing
that was the only time we did not naked
that was funny she did look like she's
naked i couldn't believe how small she
looked yeah a little
bit because well it's just kind of like
i mean we've had to give her a bath a
couple times like if she got kind of
dirty um because she looks big because
she's so fluffy like she doesn't look
fat but she looks like a big cat so
she's like yeah but if you get her wet
or if you shave it off she's like
actually pretty
thin or she's not thin but you know just
like normal cat's eyes but i'd been so
used to her being like
much larger and she looks so much larger
than pookie
and like i said pookie's four or
something so four
point two five years old so she's fully
grown
yeah and i guess like i said i guess
pookie is not gonna get any bigger
because that's just the size she's going
to be because she's kind of small
at least that her legs are short i think
that's kind of what it is she has little
bitty short legs
i was talking to the two ladies on the
path today because i have not seen a
path kitty mr mcguire
in uh
like a week and a half
and i think the last time i saw him
he was um
you know he was playing around in the
bushes like stalking a bird or whatever
and then i was gonna stop and pet him
and feed him but then the
you know the blow truck came through
there and he was like
the blow truck yeah the one that comes
and blows all the leaves and [ __ ] and
branches off the trail
and uh so the cat was like yeah [ __ ]
that and he ran under the fence and i
haven't seen him since then and like so
i was i was out today and like these two
ladies came by and they see me all the
time feeding the cat and she's like we
haven't seen him in such a long time i
hope he's okay and then that lady said
something she's like i hope a coyote
didn't get him because i've seen coyotes
in my yard and i was like coyotes what
there's coyotes around here i mean she
said bobcats too and i know there's
bobcats but i never i never saw any
coyotes around here now i don't want to
let pookie go out on the back fortune
anymore
[ __ ] coyotes
yeah again
bees necessary that run ten miles at mop
they full them up
and you guys i wouldn't know what that
means
he's talking about the army
we had this [ __ ] called
mop levels which uh
was mission oriented protective posture
that's all that damn
nuclear biological and chemical gear
and we had to do all these drills all
the time
and they had mop level one two three and
four
and mop four was all your [ __ ] on mask
charcoal suit all that stuff rubber
gloves
and they would just [ __ ] with you man
you
put you at mob level four make you stay
that way and just do drills and then run
all the [ __ ] decontamination gear and
we had all these test kits we had to do
we had to go through all that
just you know to
you have to know everything about the
[ __ ] test kits how to test if you
what kind of agent you got hit with
but it was so [ __ ] hot and there was
this he
there was this one time in
in korea
we were out in the field it was the
middle of the middle of summer and these
mosquitoes were [ __ ] eating us up
and i got tired of getting eaten by
these mosquitoes so i put i made a big
mistake
but
[Laughter]
i put mosquito repellent it came in this
[ __ ]
it's like deet and stuff yeah it came in
this green bottle that [ __ ] worked good
man that [ __ ] army mosquito repellent
and it was like baby oil
and one of the things that you could do
with it is you could use it to take off
camo paint that camel paint would stick
and get all [ __ ] grimy and you had to
shave and made you shave every day so
the only way to get the damn that [ __ ]
would clog up a razor so you had to take
bug repellent and put it on your face
to kind of make the camo paint
liquid again and then you can shave it
man you'd be doing that in your canteen
cup your canteen cup it tastes like
[ __ ]
bug propellant and [ __ ] but this [ __ ]
was [ __ ] nasty anyway
i had just
put new [ __ ] camouflage paint on and
[ __ ] mosquitoes were eating me up and
i [ __ ] took some [ __ ]
bug pellet put it all over my head and
up on my [ __ ]
forehead and [ __ ] and it was [ __ ] all
right for about an hour
then all of a sudden [ __ ] boom they
tell us that we've been hit by gas this
is all just training and we have to go
[ __ ] mop level so i'm putting all
this [ __ ] mop gear on
and we have to go through all the tests
and all that [ __ ] heat and all that
rubber gloves and [ __ ] i start sweating
all right and the sweat [ __ ] goes
down my [ __ ] forehead and picks up
all the bug spray and it goes right into
your eyes yeah and because i've got my
mask on you can't rub
so every time i open my eyes it would
just [ __ ] sting it was like you're
getting hit with damn
[ __ ] gas like like like cs gas
and i'm trying to run the damn
[ __ ] nbc i forgot what the name of
that damn [ __ ] test kit was it was
about two feet tall and about a foot on
a foot you had to carry it this big old
aluminum box had to take the top off and
there was a bunch of little things you
had to put in there it's been so long
and things would change color
and you had little dials on it and
everything i forgot what [ __ ] was called
it's obsolete now they don't use that
anymore
and me and my [ __ ] squad leader are
trying to go through this [ __ ] you know
and he said ross which one you remember
what that was and then i'm going yeah
yeah this because there's like a
procedure you had to go through
and man i was at [ __ ] mop level four
for probably about an hour hour and a
half two hours maybe it's hard to tell
time just blurs with my [ __ ] eyeballs
just screaming in their sockets i was
totally blind
towards the end of it i could not open
my eyes
good thing we weren't walking
on the plus side at least no mosquitoes
would bite your eyes
that was the last time i ever put
mosquito repellent anywhere above my
eyeball level
it was always under the eyes in case
that ever happened again
see you you learned a valuable lesson
[Laughter]
you can do it you can do it if you don't
have a gas mask on a second gas mask
starts [ __ ] getting in involved in
that [ __ ]
it gas masks and bug repellent do not
mix
learn that by [ __ ] and they're going
what's wrong with ross and as
my [ __ ] bug repellent
like you had bug repellent on it yeah
thinking so well
yeah yeah
same the way i kind of learned when i
accidentally i had a i had um
a sore neck and shoulders and i put icy
hot on the back of my neck don't do that
no tear you up oh wow that really hurt
and it was well it was just kind of i
wasn't expecting it because i'd used icy
hot on other parts of my body and it was
fine and i put it back there and i was
just like what have i done oh it was
awful thank you david june uh let's get
these super chats rolling he's asking if
we can ban somebody maybe is this
another like troll account because it's
called david june's daughters
can we like kick that person off
maybe that's what he wants me to do is
that do you want me to kick off
what are you doing i don't know
the message is deleted esther says how's
pookie she's lovely
she actually slept next to me last night
for she hadn't done that in a long time
i woke up at like 3 30 in the morning
and i was like what's that i was like oh
there's a little fuzzy lump like right
next to me and she was like
that's the little noise she makes
um yeah we wanted to say to sergeant
rocco who sent us those buckeyes yeah
man did we finish those last night right
yeah is he on here yeah yeah yeah he did
yeah he just came
pretty good yeah those were good and
it's like like i said they were tiny
tiny bit melty around the edges when
they got here but like after we
refrigerated them they hardened right
back up um we tried not to eat them all
like in one day i think it took us like
three three or four days three days to
eat them all we tried to let go we tried
to eat only like one or two a day yeah
they're good they're kind of like a um
kind of like a reese's peanut butter cup
but softer and i think they had i think
it was caramel on top of mine
i thought that was more peanut butter
was it more people but i could be wrong
it's hard to tell i think it had a
little thin thing of [ __ ] caramel on
the top of them
i was eating them all in a single bite
so
oh well see i like i have to do it in
like because like i said i've if i'm
gonna eat candy or if i'm gonna eat
something that's really like has a lot
of calories i want to savor that [ __ ] so
i'm not just gonna like pop it in my
mouth and forget about it i'm just gonna
eat a little bite and like
chew that all the way through and then
eat another little bite you know what i
mean
you have to savor it because like i said
it's you know it's that many calories
we're gonna eat that many calories you
might as well like enjoy it yeah
um and then oracle asked how's beijing
she's doing good too
she's uh she's just banned her regular
self
didn't she do i thought she did
something super funny i came out the um
i came out the bedroom the other day and
i saw her like
sauntering across the living room
because you know how she like carries
all the little stuffed animals like all
over the house her little cargo cult
thing she has going on which she does
like every single night but i never
usually catch her doing it but the other
night it wasn't like late i think it was
only like 7 p.m
and i was walking out to the kitchen to
get something and i saw her and she was
like sauntering out of my office
across the living room and she had that
little blue bunny rabbit in her mouth
and she's just like walking like and
then she saw me
and then she dropped it on the floor and
kept walking
so i don't know i don't know if she's
embarrassed by it she seems embarrassed
by it because if you catch her
because like i said what she'll do is
she'll carry it she'll put it on the
she'll drop it on the floor and then
she'll sit there and she'll like cry to
it
you know
and
but if you come around the corner and
see her doing it she stops and like acts
like totally like she's being all casual
and stuff
so i don't know
it's very weird i don't know she never
used to do that
like i said i think she cut she started
doing that when we got pookie right yeah
i don't remember her doing that before
but for some reason and she does it
every single night every night i come
out in the morning and there's little
babies there's little stuffed animals
all over and like a lot of times i wake
up in the middle of night and i hear her
doing the little cry that she does to
him which is a very distinctive little
cry
yeah it's just like this weird
kind of yeah
it's like it's really funny
she just sits there crying at these
little babies
and carrying them around the house at
her mouth it's so strange
okay
yeah sergeant roger said it was peanut
butter yeah see that's what i thought i
didn't taste any caramel they make them
to look like buckeyes i can i can't just
eat one or twenty i know it's like
that's the thing about
candy like that is that especially that
really nice chocolate peanut butter
i could easily eat a whole box of those
i just
i just you know
shouldn't
[Laughter]
if i wasn't thinking about it i said
because you know what i mean like one of
one of my favorite candies is actually
peanut m ms
and if you totally if you gave me like a
pound bag of peanut m ms i would totally
probably just eat that whole thing if i
wasn't thinking about it
what even are buckeyes though
i don't know if they're asking me to ban
people i don't bad people because i
don't have the controls right here and
we we have monitor uh we have mob well
is that person even here i assumed that
they were talking about this other
person yeah i don't know i don't know if
they turn up again then i'll then i'll
do it but i don't i don't see them this
is internet world and you know
it could be the internet world i believe
after all i believe only a fraction of
what i see in here through through
comment sections because anybody can be
anybody and anybody can do anything
so i'm not really all that worried about
it just uh there's moderators in there
if there's problems you guys sorted out
i'm not really jocking on the [ __ ]
comments all the time anyway i don't
worry about it
can't you guys sort it out camp guy says
soggy captain crunch is good get out no
captain crunch is only going as crunchy
and it tears up like the roof of your
mouth it's right there in the name
that's good captain crunch i haven't had
captain crunch in a long time crunch
berries and chips i don't like the
crunch berries [ __ ] that i just i just
like the plain i mean i'll eat them but
i would rather not then it had a peanut
butter cap and crunch
yeah that one was pretty good that one
was pretty good i didn't like really
like crunch berries a long time
i was thinking about it i haven't really
had any cereal in like a really long
time i for some reason i was thinking
about that this morning because this
morning i was kind of like when i was
out walking i was like man
i i kind of want a bowl of like frosted
mini wheats best place to get that is
over at the walmart you get the big
giant [ __ ] genuine bags of [ __ ]
what's it malto meal
they make knockoffs of all those big
yeah they're super cheap well a lot of
them like
if you get the ones in the bag at the
bottom like some of them are talking
about yeah some of them are kind of like
questionable but they're all good i
think they're all good
well it depends on what kind of cereal
you want and like what kind of cereal
you're trying to replicate
i mean you can usually get good frosted
mini wheat adjacent type cereal because
that's like a pretty simple
thing to get right
um but if you want something with a real
distinctive flavor profile they got
those fake lucky multi-meal [ __ ]
lucky charms they're exactly like the
originals i think it might be the
original i forgot i think
i think it might be the original maybe
oh it's hard to say
i don't remember i don't remember if the
name was quite the same
but um
i think the names are a little bit
different
yeah there was it's just kind of like
those knock off sodas where it's like
mountain thunder right here whatever it
is
i've tried them all i can't tell them
apart from the originals dr popper
[Laughter]
not dr pimple popper that's a whole
other but there's so much cheaper you
know you might as well just use that
there are times where you know it's hard
to beat a [ __ ] bowl of cereal
yeah like i said i haven't had one a
long time it's just i don't i don't eat
breakfast all that usually
so i kind of feel like if i bought a big
box of frosted mini wheats or
what's that other one that i like honey
bunches of oats or whatever like i don't
even know if they make that anymore but
i like that
um i feel like if i bought a big box of
that like i would eat it so seldom that
it would probably just go stale
i don't know
i mean it's better to have like for
breakfast things it's better to have
like shelf sables you know more shelf
stable stuff like you know oatmeal and
stuff like that like in the packets
because i feel like that doesn't go bad
because [ __ ] man how many [ __ ] boxes
of oatmeal do we have in there
i think there's one that's open and then
there's like two and we're talking about
like the cases
because i like the one if you go to
sam's you can get that big case that has
the one that has
apple cinnamon plain ass cinnamon and
what the [ __ ] is the other one maple and
brown sugar yeah and those are like the
only i don't really like the fruity
oatmeal flavors like strawberries and
cream is okay because remember that time
we got the fruity ones that i think was
blueberry peaches
and cream and strawberries and cream and
i only like the strawberries ones the
other ones were gross
but all the the cinnamon and apples and
maple and brown sugar that's that's my
thing so we have like a [ __ ] ton of that
but like i said i never i get up early
but
you know i'm always almost always up by
seven
but it's like i don't know i never i
never really eat bread i love breakfast
food but i just never
make it you know what i mean i don't
usually eat until
11 or 12 and then i usually eat some cut
something kind of lunch adjacent
i don't know maybe i should start eating
breakfast more i used to
oatmeal is good to add to smoothies yeah
i guess i don't know i never got into
smoothies either
but like i said i love breakfast food
i used to get up
well the thing about it is that i used
to have like a different schedule
because i used to when i worked a real
job
um
the job that i worked was late like i
worked nights i worked from 5 30 p.m
till
2 a.m
so
a lot of times i'd come home and like
i'd eat something light for dinner like
you know an egg or a piece of toast or
something then i would go to sleep so
then i wouldn't get up until like 10 or
11 and then i would have some breakfasty
kind of food then
but
you know i'd make like some crepes or
some [ __ ] like that but i don't really
do that anymore
all right so if you guys have any
questions about paranormal stuff or
unsolved mysteries anything that we did
on other shows you go ahead and uh feel
free to
ask them [ __ ] and uh jenny and i will
probably know the questions one way or
the other
but um
i don't know i'm just trying to get
warmed up the show get some alcohol in
my [ __ ] stuff yeah man you're already
like on your second one
sergeant rocco says my best buddy
roommate is irish and we have bacon and
eggs for dinner all the time honestly
that was like my favorite when i lived
alone that was like my favorite quick
dinner
was just like just plain old eggs with
pepper on them
and just buttered toast
it's like you know not even bacon i
didn't even bother with that
and it was just kind of like which is
good because you know eggs are kind of
like
they're they're they don't have that
that many calories but they're like
really nutritious okay we got a question
from oscar
we're gonna get off the food subject
get fat just talk about food all right
oscar perez uh living in florida have
you guys gone to see the robert the doll
in key west
we have not it's uh and did we talk
about this i kind of feel like we talked
robert the doll is very famous i think i
talked about this when i was talking
about like weird florida [ __ ]
he's this doll that's supposedly
possessed haunted i can't remember like
all the details just the warrens
um
i don't think well that's that's the
annabelle [ __ ] okay yeah i don't know
i'm sure the warrens were probably
involved because they're involved in
everything whether you want them they're
not they were yeah but um
yeah not anymore i think they're both
dead now yeah
but um i'm pretty sure we talked about
it on one of our shows but i can't
remember the topic of the show that we
talked about it on honestly as even
though i've lived in florida my whole
entire life pretty much um i don't i
have never been to key west i've been to
as far south as i've been as miami i've
been in miami a couple of times
but
i've never been to the everglades which
sucks because i really like to go there
but um i've never been to key west
remember we were talking to um we were
talking to our friend will the other day
uh
will with the kilt okay yeah william
walker yeah
and um he was saying that
that i should go to that we should go to
key west like for a vacation because
it's really fun down there and i've
heard that it looks cool like it looks
very old it looks kind of like new
orleansy is what it looks like he was
down there
yeah he was down there not too long ago
what was he doing just vacation he was
down there on vacation like a year or
two ago
um
i don't know like i said i've always
wanted to go but there's a lot of other
places i want to go to because i kind of
feel like i know why he asked that
because his girlfriend's coming back
from deployment he probably wants to
wants us to go
as couples i'm john beth
yeah maybe because she's probably gonna
want to take her somewhere
yeah
i just i don't know like like i said um
if i was gonna go and v if i was gonna
spend like a [ __ ] ton of money and go on
vacation i would rather get somewhere
other than florida because i feel like
i've been in florida for like a really
long time and i want to go other places
that's way down there though
it is but it's still florida and it's
like and it's hotter
it's like i don't want to go somewhere
at the bottom down here with michael
caine and [ __ ]
and the pirates and what and the pirates
yeah
i've never seen it i wouldn't mind going
yeah i still i want to go one day
because i've heard it's like really cool
it's very now it's very like beachy like
um i like that [ __ ] you know you know
what i mean it's very like margaritas
and yeah and [ __ ] like that get up there
and fish jimmy buffetty yeah
kind of i don't care kind of stuff i'm
just i'm just telling i don't [ __ ]
care
well you know it's everybody has that
point where they get drunk they don't
[ __ ] care
well i mean you know like i'm saying i
went on the vacation last time i went to
st augustine but i've always liked st
augustine because it's not really it's
got a beach but it has like a bunch of
it's not like a beachy place necessarily
it's more like a piratey spanish-y kind
of
like old
like ancient type of place and that's
like way cooler grandpa says key west is
a bomb go see hemingway's six-toed cats
yeah yeah
yeah that's right yeah cause uh is it
disturbed or something ernest hemingway
lived down there did i drop something on
the floor there what is that it looks
like a piece of chicken or something
that's what it is from you to eating
that chicken
i gave her some chicken
a few minutes ago
few minutes before the show started well
we yeah well last night you like you
grilled like a bunch of chicken yeah it
was like so healthy we were we were
proud of ourselves yeah we grilled
chicken grilled some broccoli and some
cauliflower just all over the grill she
said we
you did it yeah well i'm just saying we
because i ate it
[Laughter]
yeah i got a good price on that chicken
[ __ ] over at sabs
over there yeah get a big old [ __ ]
big sleeve of it of uh
[ __ ] thighs and thighs and legs guys
and legs and they were each each one of
them was only uh 499 522 between that
you know it's like that's a lot of
[ __ ] chicken well
and see i like dark meat i like the dark
meat chicken because i like i like
breasts and stuff too like the you know
i like the way i go
also
but honestly if
ever since i was a kid if we got you
know on the rare occasions we got kfc
everybody would give the thighs to me
because nobody liked it by me yeah
that's good
all that chinese food is thigh
yeah i think the thigh meat is like
pretty much i think
it's just it's juicy and
turkey is the same like i said i'll eat
the breast but i would rather eat like
the dark meat to me it's like the breast
it's like it gets a little bit too dry
and grainy
turkey dark meat is it has a very
different flavor though it's good it's
just it's it's much more gamy
i like that though
we're back on food well that's just what
that's what happens it's a sidetrack
show yeah that's what happens it's
science that's you're saying that i
should run for president no you don't
want me as president no no one wants
time for president trust me yeah
they got mad at trump [ __ ] he's really
bothered they got mad if you see how mad
they got a trump i'd be five times that
five times that
yeah he'd be way worse yeah you don't
want that no one wants that [ __ ] no we
don't first of all we don't deserve that
i would start off by saying ha
i say you know
i said first off my first day in prison
i want to tell you all that half y'all
are [ __ ] [ __ ] that's the first
thing i said y'all are [ __ ] half the
other [ __ ] that that's what i would
say
um and i'm sure he's i'm sure he
includes me in that yeah hell yeah equal
opportunity hater i [ __ ] hate you
know just
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
y'all are [ __ ] and i
i would make up all kinds of [ __ ] i
would do anything i would make i would
make people mad on purpose
i would be a lot like a roman emperor
and and what point what purpose would
that serve
they have no purpose
you're you're
you're you're trying to uh
you're trying to read into things there
wouldn't be any purpose to it yeah let's
all just be stupid
the purpose would be to piss people off
that'd be the purpose
kind of like it would just be kind of
like sadism you know mass punishment and
[ __ ] it would be like i would just treat
the entire country as if they were uh
[ __ ] an infantry [ __ ] company you
know
you guys would hate it
honestly though i kind of feel like that
kind of stuff like people like people
that just go out and try and make people
mad on purpose
i'm just kind of like you're not making
people mad you're just mostly just
annoying us and making us roll our eyes
with contempt that's pretty much it so
good job i would attack the ruling class
so it would never work
dj maniac says talking to a starry night
on facebook yeah they say you two are
michael's pretend parents yeah yeah
probably
[ __ ] michael michael does all kinds
of [ __ ] funny [ __ ] man he's young
enough to be our kid he doesn't yeah we
until he said like one what year he was
born one time and i said oh that was the
same year i graduated high school
they show up you know what i mean we've
done business with him we've done shirts
for him she's done album covers for them
and uh we've just [ __ ] done
promotions for them in our local area
but
i got them signed so i can
jenny could tell that story [ __ ]
jenny had this friend named imani he was
from new york and she was in the music
well she's your friend too yeah but it
started she was more jenny's friend at
first
all right she thought i was an [ __ ]
she thought i was an [ __ ] you are an
[ __ ] yeah
but after a while she's like i
understand it now i understand what you
did
see anyway
we were at dinner and she's like uh tom
what is what is your favorite
florida band and i said a starry night
because really
because we had randomly come across them
on youtube yeah i was watching them on
youtube
yeah the best thing in florida is the
starry night
[ __ ]
next thing i know [ __ ] was a couple
weeks later she goes i got your bad side
i was like what
just started night i got them signed
and i was like oh cool so i contacted
him it says congratulations and they're
like yeah uh
you got a sign
yeah
so that's how that [ __ ] started
then i was just talking
i talked to them before
they got signed yeah
but it was like months before and
michael remembered me i was i met
michael online first
and uh i think we met them in person the
first time at the grotto yeah that's the
first time because i remember michael
saying to us it's like oh you guys are
much prettier in person
i think that i think i remember saying
that
he does
first i don't wanna i don't wanna
[ __ ] out anybody or anything you know
man or [ __ ]
you know
but
michael comes off as being kind of like
this looking sexually kind of [ __ ]
ambiguous you know kind of like an
androgynous dude
he's straight as [ __ ] i mean the dude is
[ __ ]
he's real straight
but he plays these [ __ ] games like
he's flirting with you you know
but he's [ __ ] with the wrong one with
me because i'm like okay come on man i
try to grab him and [ __ ] make put him
on my lap and [ __ ] or [ __ ] try to
straddle him and throw the [ __ ] club
[ __ ] you know i mean try to get him
into some kind of female position and
he's like he starts [ __ ] laughing and
the other guys in the band are like dude
they're like pat me on the back like
that's right that's how you handle that
[ __ ] that's how you handle it he does
that [ __ ] all the time he thinks
nobody's gonna try to [ __ ] him that says
i'm gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] you
know i'm handing my drink to jenny i'm
gonna [ __ ] this dude
if i can you know it's
it's it's fun and games you know i'm
playing with him it's just uh
there's gonna be repercussions if you
play with me yeah i mean
someone's going to get butt horses it's
like a [ __ ] yeah
it's like a game of chicken or something
but
no they're they're [ __ ] uh
they're a great band and [ __ ] um it's
funny because like
this was a couple years back
michael says some [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] this is kind of sideways he's
just like
you know it's so cool to be here [ __ ]
in in orlando with you guys and hanging
out white people i was like what i was
like what
and i looked and realized that they were
all hispanic and i was like oh yeah yeah
i guess so
because we don't we're so used to it
here see it's a heavily hispanic area
down south
well yeah but here it's mixed hispanic
and white and it's just and they're all
kind of well here it's kind of everybody
because it's orlando it's orlando so a
lot of people come here as tourists and
they're like oh hey this is nice i think
i'll stay or you know or they move back
here when they retire or whatever but
the regulars and everybody that we hang
out with
they're a mixture of hispanics and
whites and then they're mixed
hispanic and white what they call white
hispanics as if hispanics are white a
lot of hispanics are white brazil was
you know half white
i went to brazil when i grew up in
brazil i just blended right in with them
because there's just so many irish and
german and stuff
but anyway um
it was funny that
he he says
it's cool to be up here hanging out with
you white people
because i didn't realize that they were
hispanic because it just
a lot of our friends are hispanic we
don't even really notice it they're just
people to us and they're just they're
interested when everyone's gothed out
they're all not really you don't really
think about it they're all we're all
into the same music we're all wearing
the same clothes and [ __ ] we all have
the same culture so it's kind of like
you get to the point to where there was
a time when italians weren't considered
to be white
now that's a ridiculous idea that
italians are not working but that wasn't
that long ago it wasn't a long long ago
but a lot of the united states is like
that now
a lot of those artificial divisions are
not really there like they were
10 15 20 years ago
um
you lose track of who's hispanic and the
same way you would lose track of who's
italian
well like i said especially in florida
in florida yeah it's just we're all
speaking the same language we nobody has
accents really not in this area
they all kind of like the same culture
so it's not like um
it's not kind of like racially based or
ethnic based identities it's more like
cultural based identities they like goth
stuff
yeah and so it's kind of like a racing
to its own i guess
but i think everybody else
everybody else is like that too though
you go to these damn redneck bars we're
hanging out [ __ ] mannequins and
rednecks and [ __ ] coming in you look at
them they're like half of them are
hispanic
but they're rednecks
[Laughter]
hispanic rednecks yeah
they're wearing this redneck clothes
they're [ __ ]
where they're wearing [ __ ]
bro bro clothes and stuff with the big
[ __ ] shorts and bro clothes
what would you call it oh my god so
what do you call that i don't even know
what that is it's not a look i mean it
is a look obviously giant bermuda shorts
and [ __ ] they're cargo shorts they're
not bermuda shorts usually yeah cargo is
that what you call them and then they
have like tennis shoes
and then like sandals sandals or crocs
if they're off if they're really with
like a hawaiian shirt or or a [ __ ]
polo shirt or a polo shirt and uh it's
to me we would call those yuppies kind
of back in the day
yeah but or preppies
yeah preppies but they they've brought
it they they turned the bromometer
a lot harder you know what i mean
they're more fred flintstone than they
were before
and they're fatter now
aren't we all yeah but well that's you
remember we're watching because i've
been re-watching like when i'm not
watching movies and stuff when i just
want to like turn my brain off
i've been re-watching gordon ramsay's
hotel hell on toby
and there was one episode
um set in florida as it happened it was
i think it was fort pierce yeah it was
so it was like south florida
and there was this guy who was running
this restaurant slash hotel i can't
remember what it's called the inlet
something like that it was like right on
the beach side
and this guy was like the platonic i
think i said this it's a platonic ideal
of the bro look like these are the
people that like come at mannequin
sometimes
who was the dude that owned this place
it's like he's just this blandly
sort of
you know it's like not even attractive
because he's not like not even
interesting enough to be attractive but
he's just like not offensive looking i
guess
just kind of like this white dude which
is kind of like blonde hair buzz cut
they have like a polo shirt that's
several sizes too big
tucked into
like a pair of those khaki shorts right
that are knee length or a little bit
below knee length that are also a little
bit too big
and they have those big clunky
tennis shoes like those big basketball
shoes
and they stand there with their legs
like that and they just look like so
dumpy
and it's just kind of like i
i have worked for so many dudes that
looked that dressed and looked like that
it's like it's like a whole
i don't know what factory they're coming
out of yeah but just call them dude bros
thank you david june yeah we call them
dude bros i don't know if there's a name
for it
yeah
what's he doing that's what i mean i'm
just so is this the person that you
wanted me okay so yeah put okay well
we'll do that um
yeah so
[Music]
that's yeah it's like i don't know
there's a there's
not really a name for them but it's just
it was funny because when i was watching
that episode of hotel hell that guy that
owned that
place in florida
was just like a really like i was like
that's that that's like every dude that
comes in mannequins sometimes and it's
like woo like the pro type juice i'm
like they all look like that
like scott is one of them yeah kind of
scott is kind of like that although
like she we're talking about newbie no
from
[Laughter]
he would he
is basically a white dude
or hispanic
in this area
or something in between
there's occasionally a black one but
they're mostly white and hispanic type
guys yeah i very very rarely see this
they're almost always wait
they're kind of like
they're kind of like a they dress kind
of preppy
i would call but like a preppy at a golf
match or s or i would think
maybe they're golfing
maybe they're
i don't know what they're
doing they're wearing these cargo shorts
and an eyezod shirt and maybe like some
crocs and they might have a baseball cap
on
maybe or those bit like i said or those
big clunky basketball shoes or big like
yeah sometimes sometimes you see that
too yeah and they would like uh would
love to go to the game they probably
watch
probably watch pro football
they probably like pro basketball they
probably golf
um they don't have any kind of tastes
outside the normal generic mainstream
they probably really like jimmy buffett
they would probably what else kind of
music would they like see i don't even
have any idea they probably they would
listen to rap too they probably listen
to rap too
um there's just there's no way to
explain these these guys
i don't know what they are and they're
just like it's like a super generic they
tend to be overweight now
they're overweight yeah they usually
have like they some of them look like
they have varying sizes of like uh sea
turtle underneath their shirts which are
inevitably tucked in yeah they tuck them
in a lot and they have a belt on the
shorts yeah yeah which i always thought
was very sometimes if the shirt is not
tucked in the shirt is like four sizes
too big for them yeah
um so it's flat so like the sleeves are
too yeah and they're usually with
some kind of yuppy basic [ __ ] white
girl
who's also wearing shorts and flip-flops
and
a shirt and
they always they always come in the butt
no matter what bar it is
they always come in and go woo
woo like they're like as soon as they
come in like it's a huge party like
everyone's gonna turn around
and everybody's like oh here we go
yeah
and it's
we don't know what to call them it's
it's it's it's a subculture onto its own
but there's so many of them it's like
the mainstream yeah see i don't even
think it's a subculture because
subculture implies that there's a larger
culture and i think that's the larger
culture
i guess but i don't really know much
about it
they're roughly dressed in between
in florida
it's like they've dressed they're
dressed up
to either go to the golf course or the
beach or both
that's how they're dressed like yeah
yeah
although i did kind of i laughed and
they're not poor
no they're not poor they're usually like
yeah they're usually like solidly upper
middle class yeah
well it's funny because i laughed
because that that um episode of hotel
hell
like
you know he was the owner of the place
and he just come in like with that derpy
walk that he had with those big clunky
shoes
and um
gordon was like why don't you go home
and come back when you're like dressed
like an owner yeah and then he come back
came back looking maybe two percent
better because at least he put like
slacks on instead of those stupid shorts
and like actual shoes
but
the thing about that dude was
that he was like a vacuous
black hole of personality yeah it was
nice too he looked like there was just
nothing going like not stupid
but he just looked like there was
nothing going on in there yeah like you
would talk to him and he'd just be like
oh yeah i gotta do that he's just he
looked like there was like no
he was like a personality
vacuum what was funny is that they don't
[ __ ] with me like they used to
because because you know i'm going out
with jetty but back in the day
when i was single
at over at ibarr
those kind of women were [ __ ] [ __ ]
super super [ __ ] oh yeah yeah they're
easy
and
they like to go off guys if they like
well they like the guy
and i'd walk by them they'd grab you
where are you going where are you going
they all wanted to talk yeah no no no i
gotta go you don't want to talk to him
it'll be an endless circle of
[ __ ]
so what do you do for a living how many
credit cards do you have
what car do you drive it's gonna be some
[ __ ] like that honestly
what college did you go to
well like i said there's kind of an
equivalent because a lot of dudes like
that have like a fetish kind of thing
for gotham yeah as well but they're a
lot more threatening about it
you know what i mean
yeah they ask you all kinds of crazy
questions and [ __ ] so
because they assume that you're into
like freaky sections right yeah and it's
actually them that are in a freaky
[ __ ] yeah i'm like don't project your
[ __ ] on me man that's them
so
yeah
but it's funny because
if you if you entertain the conversation
after two or three times you realize
that it will be the same conversation
over and over and over again
and the kind of questions that they will
ask you will come to be the same
question in the same order
like they're running off a program they
reminded me of korean girls korean girls
were the same way
i wasn't in korea it's like x y and z
yeah they're going through they're going
through a program of priorities
they were just different priorities for
korea
guamo khan says i feel like these folks
were sugar ray's target audience back
then yeah it was like all that kind of
like 90s
yeah bro
pop punk
type of vibe
these are these were the people that
were that were into that cancer yeah
creed greed um who was those other bands
yeah sugar ray was a good one what the
[ __ ] were those people oh the [ __ ]
fool fighters
foo fighters might have been a little
too indie for them
[Laughter]
i was kind of feeling like who's that
what's that one [ __ ] band that i'm
thinking of who's that one that
everybody shits on nickelback nickelback
yeah that's why they're like the guy
fieri fieri
of uh yeah it's like guy fieri but not
not quite as like outlandish as that
at least guy fieri sort of has a
personality even though it's really
super annoying
said the flock of seagulls thomas this
shirt is the killer's thing it's flock
of cigals it's a flock of cigars yes
these [ __ ] stevens ago
there's four of them four of them and
all the different differences and
they're all looking sternly yeah
actually there's two
that one and yeah there's two different
ones i got you that for christmas then
yeah
zack says hey i just come in and the
first thing i hear is freaky sex [ __ ]
what i miss
zach's in here
yeah he just got here yeah dj maniac
says students you dare pick on guy fieri
he's a wonderful human being i will
admit i like
uh what's that show he does uh diners
drive-ins and dives but i like it mostly
for the you know restaurants and [ __ ]
like that that they uh that he goes to
because he's like a little annoying
i've never been to one of his
restaurants though is he the one that
does the donkey sauce
is it called donkey sauce it's made in
mexico
[Laughter]
made with actual donkeys i don't know
what the [ __ ] is that distracted am i
thinking donkey sauce or who does boom
boom sauce what the [ __ ] it's some kind
of irritating name like that i don't
know i can't remember what it is though
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
that's kind of like that's there's all
like okay so now that we're talking
about [ __ ] hot sauce called colon
cleaner
yeah i've seen that too
well everybody likes that kind well the
the famous one is ass blaster or ass
blast or ass blaster
something like that and it's like and
the cartoon on the front of it is
exactly what you would imagine
yeah donkey sauce sounds very well is is
that guy fairy um or is or does he have
some other kind of annoyingly named
sauce
zach says um
are you are either you a fan of any
sitcoms i've been watching a lot of
clips from the nanny and i can say is a
gay girly friend dresser as sexy as [ __ ]
um
fran drescher looked pretty good in her
in her [ __ ] prime but man her uh
her voice was just annoying i i couldn't
i couldn't get it's my voice isn't it
yeah damn
i just know that that was that was for
me that was from man with two brains
to
new york
no thank you
yeah i wonder if that's her real voice
or if that's just like a footballer like
that no i've seen interviews with her
are we talking like old sitcoms or new
sitcoms like as far as like old sitcoms
go uh
most of them are garbage i can't really
think of any really good ones that i i
mean i can think of some that i liked
back in the day like when i was a kid
yeah but you wouldn't like them today
but i don't know if i'd like because you
know when i was a kid i used to i used
to like like facts of life and [ __ ] like
that but it's like i don't know i
haven't watched it for a long time so i
don't know now as far as like newer ones
go i mean how can you not love arrested
development although it's not like
that's not really a sitcom because it's
almost kind of like
it's not in a standard sitcom format
it's more like it's more movie-like i
guess
um you know in the office obviously i
liked a lot of the kind of old
british uh shows i liked the old british
shows like the young ones and stuff
which again was kind of like a sitcom
but not really
most american sitcoms came off of a damn
[ __ ] mass production machine they
were very vacuous there wasn't much
comedy there oh yeah 30 rock was good
too yeah they're trying
to put out as many episodes as they
could the laugh tracks and everything
you can go back and watch that [ __ ] on
on youtube i've tried to go back and
watch some of the classics that i
remember they're unwatchable
by today's standards
they're just
annoying very very annoying
well they're very not funny well by
today's standards they're very contrived
and we've talked like talked about this
before
where
comedy it seems like it's really hard to
do ageless comedy
yeah
even i remember how funny eddie murphy's
delirious was go back and watch it it's
not funny
it was funny then but it's not funny now
i mean i've seen some like old comedy
stuff that's still funny but it seems
very very hard to do it's very hard it
wasn't even delirious it was raw that
was the first one
uh eddie murphy that the uh go back and
watch eddie murphy raw it's not funny
although it was funny back then it just
yeah i remember it being funny i am
watching a long time what made it funny
back in those days is that you couldn't
believe he was saying that it was all
shocking because but now it's not john
yeah anymore humor humor has a lot to do
with the unexpected
so he was saying things you didn't
expect
but now that's standard well now
everybody says everybody says things
like that so so it's just like yeah
whatever
and if you go to some of those sitcoms
the the main mechanism for the laughter
is actually the laugh tracks
if you were to take the laugh track out
of those things you wouldn't know when
to laugh because you wouldn't laugh
yeah you just sit there stone face yeah
what what because i don't get it because
there's basically a laugh track at the
end of everything pretty much somebody
says
and they're trying to get get you
rolling through this
this dialogue
thinking that it's funny but they're
tricking you into into thinking that
it's funny it's not funny
and you know [ __ ] and living color
was a little bit funny but if you took
the chat laugh track away it wasn't fun
it wasn't as funny
um there's a lot of stuff that just it
wasn't funny
yeah yeah yeah the young ones was from
the 80s that was like a british sitcom i
watched a couple episodes of the young
i'd you know i've memorized them back in
the old days um and i had them on tape
and then like i lost them and [ __ ] like
that but i watched a couple episodes the
other day
for some reason and uh that shit's still
funny sorry
well because a lot of the humor there
was not so much any kind of humor that's
built around shock value like you said
it's not going to age well no um i kind
of feel like the reason that people
still think [ __ ] like monty python and
stuff like that is funny is because it's
absurdist
it doesn't have to do with there was
some wit in there too yeah it doesn't
have to do with like the standards of
the time necessarily um you know some of
it is just like just crazy [ __ ] or
nonsensical in a lot of ways if that's
done well that's you know it'll be funny
for forever because it's not tied to a
particular time period for me the
ultimate example of terrible
dated comedy
all came off the wb channel remember
warner brothers channel
and it was like in living color
the wayans brothers there was a couple
of other ones
um
that i've forgotten
they were just trying to make a lot of
programs very quickly
and um
the writing was very fast and very you
could tell mass production type writing
and it all hinged upon the laugh track
if there wasn't a laugh track there it
would look absurd
go back and look at it it's right there
on youtube you won't be able to get
through any of that [ __ ] and that's kind
of that was the 90s
mid 90s and that was like the zenith
of that type
of television programming and and i'm
glad that it's gone i'm glad that that's
gone that was [ __ ] that was really
garbage that was the beginning of the
end of television
um it television just became kind of
played out
david june says youtube big bang theory
without the laugh track it's cringe yeah
i can imagine i've seen some episodes of
that because somebody used to like tape
a bunch of [ __ ] for me because i didn't
have a tv and um you know or i didn't
have cable or anything and i watched
some of it and it's like some of it was
kind kind of crack a smile but it's not
really that funny uh camp guy says the
office you but actually the uk office is
hysterical and the u.s one even though i
only saw the first few seasons that was
also pretty [ __ ] funny um you know it
and it probably still is that's that's
not still on is it now that's uh yeah
french and saunders that was good um
beowulf says the monster still holds up
hella good see and i feel like the
reason that the monsters and adams
family for example are still funny
is because
of the concept
that concept it's like this kind of fish
out of water look they're the weirdos
but they're the only normal people that
is a timeless concept it doesn't have
anything to do with shocking anybody it
doesn't have anything that's always
funny yeah somebody mentioned um [ __ ]
um friends garbage yeah garbage well i
didn't think it was funny back then no
not funny at all and what friends what
friends did
is friends was a substitute for friends
if you didn't have friends you could sit
around just watch friends
and it made you feel like you knew you
you had some people that you knew
i think that's what it was a lot of
people liked it at the time
i watched some of it because it was just
because it was on television
but what it would do is just kind of
lull you into kind of a relaxed state
you know what i mean yeah but i think it
that only worked back then that wouldn't
work now i don't think
i mean i haven't seen like i said social
media destroyed all that i haven't seen
any sitcoms that are on nowadays because
there are still sitcoms on nowadays um
but like i said other than like weird
ones that aren't really sitcoms like
arrested development um because i
[ __ ] loved arrested development i
think i have it on like uh i think i
have a i would think that something i
would there's no such thing as broadcast
television anymore but i would think
that everything is cable i would think
that network television
sitcoms nowadays must be pandering to
the lowest common denominator people
that don't have internet so that means
very old people
very poor people but even poor people
have [ __ ] internet now so it's got to
be bad
and probably have some taste so
what has taste
poor people
now you'd be surprised i mean you know
my aunt still watches television and
thinks it's normal but she lives in
louisiana and she's stagnant it's like
she was back in the 80s
she's still in the 80s frame of mind
well if there's no reason yeah if
there's no reason and that's
and she'll sit there and watch
television you know when because i had
to live with there in that damn hotel
when my dad was having the [ __ ]
bypass surgery i lived there what two
weeks with her yeah and she would sit
there and watch television she'd watch
all her televisions it was quite a study
to watch this old lady watch television
and see the
it was like a time warp seeing somebody
who was living back in the 80s
and totally enthralled with
mindless
corporate drivel just
[ __ ]
you know
yeah lapping it up you know
lapping it up and i'm just going like
that's just now i'm on my tablet [ __ ]
trying to get away from that [ __ ] you
know
yeah mango says michael shannon would
make a good herman monster
now that you mention it i hadn't thought
of him even though we just watched take
shelter with him in it
he actually would make a good herman
monster
he just he reminds me do you know who he
reminds me of like the look of him and a
little bit the way he acts you he
reminds me of richard keel
the guy that played
jaws in uh the james bond movies and
also he played iga he was in he was in
human duplicators he was in like a lot
of b movies
but uh yeah michael shannon kind of
reminds me of that asses if we had seen
uh michael shannon and bugs yes which
one is bug oh it's so good i don't think
you've seen it okay um it's actually i
think ashley judd is in it it came out
in
late 90s early 2000s i think i saw in
the theater and then i saw it again like
on cable
it's about yeah michael shannon is in it
and he's basically he's one of those
dudes that thinks that
um
that the
fire it's been a while since i've seen
it but he thinks that the government
like implanted chips like in his skin or
whatever
and he's like in this hotel room and
it's all like covered with tin foil and
yeah
or no he thinks there's bugs under his
skin okay and so the whole point of the
story like it's this psychological
horror thing about ashley judd like kind
of falling love them falling in love and
stuff but then her kind of like his
madness like rubbing off on her kind of
and it's just kind of like this [ __ ]
up like dynamic that happens where she
kind of starts to believe it too and
it's just like it's really really good
it's a really good movie um i think it
was on i think i saw it it popped up on
hulu or something like that the other
day and i was like man we need to do
like a retrospective on this there was a
lookout movie there's a movie we watched
a couple of months back
called bugs
i remember the trailers scared the [ __ ]
out of me when i was a kid back in the
70s
about bugs that would get on you and
they would catch on fire they would they
would get hot remember that well we yeah
we just watched that it was it was just
called bugs bugs no i think it was just
called bug because i said don't confuse
it with the michael shannon one okay see
the bug or bump because this one was
from the 70s yeah like late 70s i
remember uh i remember seeing i remember
seeing the trailer for it scared the
[ __ ] out of me when i was a kid i must
have been about six or seven when i saw
it when i saw the trailer
but then when we saw the movie the
[ __ ] was ridiculous it was
pretty good it's just the way they ended
dude fell in a hole and blew up boom
that end the end the end
that was well you know they were sick of
filming it they were just kind of like
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it just throw them
up yeah the end god damn it let's go
home
i was like that's it that's the end
yeah it was something yeah i had totally
forgotten that william friedkin directed
bug same guy that did uh the exorcist
and among other things knife
configuration
which it's one of those hit or miss oh
german's bringing up ghostwatch i wrote
uh because i'd heard so much about
ghostwatch
because i i like british [ __ ] you know
what i mean tv british movies and all
that kind of stuff so i'd heard so much
about it and i was like man i need to
see that [ __ ] so i watched it and i
wrote like a big long blog post about it
it was kind of like one of those man it
was so well done
what it was was it was made to look like
they showed it on halloween one year
right like yeah 1992.
they made it look like a real
not necessarily a news broadcast but
they said hey we're gonna do this show
it's halloween so we're gonna do this
actual news show where we're gonna go to
this family's house and investigate
their poltergeist
um and then like things go horribly
wrong like it the poltergeist turns out
to be real like all the scary [ __ ]
starts to happen
but they too but they totally sold it as
like this is a real
ghost [ __ ] like you know what i mean it
was like a real ghost show investigation
they had actual like tv presenters that
everybody knew like throughout the whole
country and they had them like totally
being playing it straight and acting
like oh my god all of this poltergeist
[ __ ] is really happening it was really
really well done and apparently it was
so well done this is back in 1992 this
is way before the blair witch project
so people were watching it going holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] like these people were
actually like did and all this horrible
[ __ ] like scary [ __ ] was happening and
they even had like people they had a um
a line you could call in they had like
people like
you know that seemed like real people
but they were calling in like saying oh
my god shit's moving in my house and
it's like the headless it was so so good
it was just really really well done i
need i actually need to watch that again
because i really liked it a lot but like
i said it was kind of ahead of its time
it was very
it's not exactly found footage it was
more like a mockumentary type thing
but because they made it look like a
real tv broadcast
thank you sergeant rocco
yeah pre blair witch it was yeah blair
witch project was what 1999
um yeah this was 92 that they did that
rocco sent us ten dollars and he didn't
even [ __ ] didn't even ask a question
or even say anything during the damn
super chat
okay i guess because we asked to answer
this question maybe that's what it was
yeah maybe
yeah um
yeah mango said someone did kill
themselves after watching it yeah they
did
um it was it was a was it a kid or a
teenager
i kind of feel like watched the ghost
watch thing and was so upset like
thinking that all this like ghost [ __ ]
was real
that they
committed suicide i think they were like
a little bit developmentally challenged
though i will say that
i'm gonna have to put this off oh oh oh
you guys i wanted to tell you guys
something i'm gonna go ahead and tease
this [ __ ] there you are
oh i know i bought a new hat
i bought a new hat and this shit's gonna
be here probably in another week or so
it's a leather daddy hat all right
hat is gay as [ __ ] [ __ ] zachary's
gonna [ __ ] love it it's a leather
daddy [ __ ] leather [ __ ] military
[ __ ]
it's it's a it it's a [ __ ] sucking hat
it's the hat you put on if you're gonna
[ __ ] start something
[Laughter]
leather daddy pottage club just in case
you gonna suck some [ __ ] you gonna put
that [ __ ] on [ __ ] i'm gonna decorate
that [ __ ] i'm gonna put a [ __ ] skull
on the front of it
because i got this i got this [ __ ]
thing that i'm gonna do
i'm going to make a [ __ ] um a rob
halford uh costume
make a robin that's right yeah yeah i
got a lot of it i got a lot of the
costumes yeah i'm getting [ __ ]
sacks [ __ ] sending me super chats
thank you very much that's what happened
says i don't think i'll love it because
i'm not that kinky but i'm sure mr toby
and his apple dick will love it
[Laughter]
i'll sh i can show you guys a picture of
a [ __ ] i got this [ __ ] ordered on
amazon it was a 40 hat
because it's real yeah it's kind of like
a leather [ __ ] kind of nazi looking
[ __ ] hat
military
kind of like an old 1930s police hat
i'm gonna put a [ __ ]
silver skull on it i'm gonna get like a
sleeveless leather jacket i'm gonna get
a [ __ ] studded belt spandex pants a
[ __ ] whip the whole night i'm gonna
get a straight
leather daddy outfit um i'm gonna wear
this [ __ ] to the club that's one thing
i'm gonna do but i'll wear it on a show
too
wear it on the show that would be super
fun i want to get a [ __ ] screaming
for vengeance [ __ ] get it before
halloween see we can do like you can
wear it's gonna be a straight up gonna
be a straight up [ __ ] rob halford
costume
it's gonna look good
i haven't decided what i'm gonna dress
up i i haven't decided what i'm gonna
dress up as for halloween yet
i thought about it but i haven't decided
so i guess i'd better think of something
anytime i'm feeling like exceptionally
leather daddy i'll [ __ ] pull that hat
out and put that [ __ ] on in the middle
of the show
and all kinds of [ __ ] money will come
in david jan said thomas breaking the
law i'm breaking breaking the law
breaking your jaw breaking your jaw
sergeant rocco said sorry i never
donated before so i did it wrong that's
what he said said i wanted to mention
you needing to do a carl panzram board
game jenny
oh my god i think there are some serial
killer board games out there i should
maybe look into doing that
yeah i thought of a couple other ones i
wanted to do too oh i'm actually on that
[ __ ] leather daddy outfit on the back
instead of putting instead of putting
[ __ ] judas priest on there i'll put a
picture of [ __ ]
ram on there
painting a pants around and i'll put the
word panzeram on there
my pants around outfit oh my god
the [ __ ] really gonna go we're gonna
go rape some bombs
or actually make bombs rape each other
making bums rape each other breaking
bombs
that [ __ ] was crazy
and he was a crazy bad that was in the
1930s wasn't it and everybody was kind
of an idiot back then yeah
back in the 30s just jumping well i mean
you could get away with more [ __ ] back
then you could just jump on a train like
that and pull a gun out okay you bombs
start [ __ ]
oh my god that's [ __ ] so crazy [ __ ]
yeah one i feel like that probably
wouldn't even occur to most people no it
wouldn't even occur
even back then no it wouldn't occur to
most people nowadays either but i'm just
saying wait but especially back then
thank you mr roboto
that's a question for you
might you know how one gets a
prescription for anabolic enhancers
asking for a friend i.e myself looking
to bulk up somebody's asking me this who
yeah who's saying that mr roboto mr
what state does he live in he lives in
the united states
what are you asking me for i don't know
oh no i'm asking him
does my ass look like google no
they're saying i'm a secretary said i
must do all this [ __ ] yeah yeah
honest you know what um i think it'd be
really cool if you was mr roboto asking
this if you embroidered a patch that
said [ __ ] hat oh yeah and put it
right on the hat to himself yeah it says
all these [ __ ] gotta be sucked
that's what's gonna say all these
[ __ ] all these [ __ ] gotta do
just
thank you david june for fun
all right roboto
all right
anabolic enhancement
okay
best way the easiest way to go about
this i don't know how old you are where
what state you live in or what country
or anything
go get on get on your tablet and go to
[ __ ]
trt
clinics near me and google that [ __ ] and
see what comes up
and to see if there's a testosterone
replacement therapy clinic in your area
check the ratings of it through google
you know make sure customer satisfaction
is good
on the closest one near you
call them up tell them you want an
appointment
what they're going to do is they're
going to give you a [ __ ] blood test
say i want a blood test i want to see
what my testosterone levels are
depending on how cool the doctor is in
florida they're very [ __ ] cool okay
they know what you're in there for
they're gonna give you a [ __ ] blood
test
uh depending on what your age is they're
already gonna have an idea based on your
symptoms and everything [ __ ] what
your test levels are
they're going to [ __ ] um
probably prescribe they're going to
prescribe you
testosterone
testosterone scipionate you inject it
yourself and then they're probably going
to put you on h
which is um
it's a fertility drug it keeps your uh
[ __ ] gonads working that way you're
not shooting blanks when you're under
the influence of testosterone because if
you start shooting a bunch of
testosterone your nuts are going to shut
down because why why would they need to
make anything
because it's looking in the bloodstream
lazy ass nuts yeah they're looking in
the bloodstream going oh he got plenty
of testosterone we don't need to work so
it shuts down next let's just put our
little nut feet back yeah next thing you
know you're shooting blanks
so you got to fool the system you got to
tell the nuts to continue to [ __ ]
work and produce testosterone get a job
nuts right
so then you're on trt
hmm
okay trt depending on how low your
system was is 100 milligrams per week
excellent trt is 200.
200 milligrams of [ __ ] testosterone
scipione per week is almost like a mild
testosterone almost like a mild steroid
cycle but you can run that 24 hours a
day
seven days a week for the rest of your
[ __ ] life once you go on test you
will not want to come off of it
why would you
you now have
the testosterone blood count
of like six 13 year olds
okay
or three 20 year
olds um it doesn't matter how much you
drink it doesn't matter how little sleep
you get you're always going to have
[ __ ] optimal
hormones in your bloodstream which is
something that an 18 year old would only
dream of you know that would be a one in
a million 18 year old
that has
16 1200 nanograms per deciliter [ __ ]
testosterone in his bloodstream 24 7.
it's over time
that will have quite an effect on you
it might take two or three years
but it'll burn a lot of fat off you
you'll build up a lot of muscle if
you're training
if you're not training
you'll gain about half of what a guy
would had he been training
it will also take a little bit longer
but you but you do tend to burn fat
because your metabolism is running at a
really strong rate
it also fixes all your joints and
[ __ ] helps with bone density
does a lot of things that would be
associated with age reversal
now
because you're now have now replaced
your own an endogenous testosterone
with exogenous testosterone coming in
from the outside
you now are violating
the laws of nature see
you don't need to produce your own
testosterone anymore
which opens up in new doors you can now
start
messing with anabolics
without having to worry about the
hormonal crashes involved with coming
off of antibiotic anabolic cycles
there's stuff out there like anavar deca
de rabalen [ __ ] winstrol
uh [ __ ] i wouldn't mess with
trenbolone but
there's a lot of other stuff that you
can
take
for a couple months at a time that would
make drastic changes to you and you come
off of it and you won't [ __ ] because
you're on a trt you won't have that
hormonal crash where you'll lose
everything you gained and [ __ ]
blow up and build a lot of fat you know
you're you're not playing that game
because you got trt and support
you can get that stuff prescribed to you
in certain states
here in florida there are some
trt clinics that will get get you anavar
if they
if they're cool with you
that has a lot to do with it i think but
most of them don't
um
you can get all that stuff it all
depends on that doctor
let's be honest doctors are glorified
drug dealers
they'll give you what you they what you
want if you've
gone through all the steps and paid for
everything you had to pay for
now you start [ __ ] putting on a
[ __ ] 150 pounds of muscle on top of
what you had before they're going to
start backing off on that man
they do not want to give give you
something that's unrealistic
dudes die from this [ __ ] okay
but they don't die from the steroids or
the or the anabolics they're dying from
all that mass that they gained from it
so there's demis diminishing returns
with everything
you start [ __ ] going you're pushing
230 pounds of [ __ ] muscle on a frame
your heart is just not designed to push
that much
blood through that much material
i mean it a 230 pound muscle man is
[ __ ] under more stress than a 230
pound fat person but many times more
that's why they drop like flies
you got to be careful about how much
weight you gain
with this
you don't want to get that big
all right i do not recommend going above
genetic potential which is genetic
potential is what you would have gained
without it
it's just that
to reach genetic potential naturally can
take decades and when you're 40 or 50
you don't have decades because each year
your performance starts trailing off so
you'll never reach it
you don't want to gain that much weight
you don't want to get any bigger than
that dude
and he's pushing it
so you have to keep your mind right
with all that
check for a trt clinic in your area
that's all i'm going to say
go through all of the medical procedures
you need to go through
to get on testosterone replacement
that's first step
you start [ __ ] around with black
market stuff
you're you're you're you're
you're risking things because you don't
know what it is exactly you're taking
um
well that's kind of true of anything
yeah black market i got a piece yeah
some of the biggest [ __ ] in the
world they'll be on and you know they're
on youtube
one of them was a german guy just
talking he just he said he was huge he's
he's done them all
and really he said the best one was just
testosterone
250 milligrams per week which that's
only 50 milligrams more than what i take
and i'm prescribed that
um he takes 250
and um
it's something that you can run all the
time
and you can get huge if you're [ __ ]
training and eating right
the difference is that it will take
longer
it might take four years and i might
take five years
but that's a lot safer and a lot easier
on you than taking these exotic [ __ ]
very powerful
steroids that where you're constantly
going way up and then losing it and then
going up and all this [ __ ] up and
down and up and down you don't want that
that'll really [ __ ] you up you just want
a
slow gradual
climb and then you plateau out and then
you want to run that until you're in
your 70s and then your 80s and you die
um
and yeah trt can [ __ ] keep you very
young
there's a 73 year old chinese guy that
looks like a 30 year old because he's
done just that about 200 to 250
milligrams of testosterone
steady
for you know
20 years and he looks great
and he's not under a lot of stress that
[ __ ] there looking at that 73
year old dude and he's just [ __ ] in
perfect condition he's [ __ ] great
looking he looks young
i i don't see any problem with him
living to a hundred and being strong at
a hundred
jack o'lane lived way into his 80s might
have been early 90s and he was strong
his whole life
and he wasn't
lucky enough to have
um test he was using anavar to do that
which it's close but not quite he would
have been better off had he just done
tests probably
so don't be impatient
just take your time do it right
david june says jenny you're still going
to review that thanks killing dvd i sent
you for thanksgiving this year yeah we
definitely are doing that remind us so
we'll do it again well yeah i'll i'll
keep it written down because um
yeah
man thanksgiving is coming up yeah i
mean you know in a few months but it
always seems like once once it gets to
this time of the year like i said
once it's in september even though it's
still hot this is like still kind of my
favorite part of the year
all fall going up into christmas and
stuff like that but it always seems like
i guess because i like this time of year
so much that it just goes too fast
and then before you know it christmas is
over and life sucks again
but you know
like i said i was thinking about i was
thinking about halloween
i don't know
i gotta i gotta think of something to do
for a costume
what day does halloween fall on this
year sunday i don't know i think it
falls on a sunday
so it's not like a big show night but
we're we still do a show that day so we
could do a halloween special yes mr
roberta says look up trt and try trt
first don't expect to become the rocker
or mike tyson
um
yes
you could become the rock
but that might take
i don't know how old you are
but that might take five or six years
and maybe some assistance from some
other stuff
winstrol maybe on top of it but not for
a long couple months of wind struck you
have to train you have to eat right to
look like that
i don't know what your frame looks like
or how much you weigh or how old you are
i mean it's and what your genetics are
like
part of the reason why those dudes end
up looking like that not only because
what they're taking their training
but how their genes respond
to testosterone and anabolics some
people don't respond that well they just
got shitty genetics for it
other people got great genetics my genie
my genes are great
i gain a lot of weight and a lot of
muscle without working out that hard i
don't work out that hard
i work out twice a week but not that
hard just
compared to what i was doing in the army
it's like easy
um
and
i'm 52 now
if i worked hard i'd probably twice as
big as you see me right now
i think part of it was diet though also
i probably wasn't eating enough
if i eat a lot of chicken breasts man
yeah
uh jenny i have a book to recommend to
you a most malicious murder by melanie
fletcher it's kind of jack the
ripper-ish and the detectives are edgar
allen poe and charles dodgson aka lewis
carroll that sounds
right up my alley so yeah i wrote it
down over here because that'll
definitely be going on my wish list
thank you zach speaking of gay stuff i
need to make an appointment at the
cootie clinic soon because of reasons
how [ __ ] is it they require a 20 bill
for entry lol okay yeah that's pretty
funny
yeah esther says halloween is on sunday
i thought it was too because i think
that
usually
yeah because halloween is always on the
same day of the week as my birthday is
because my birthday is september 26th
and then halloween is always on this end
of my birthday is on a sunday this year
too so i figured halloween was probably
also on a sunday
man like i said i'm kind of i don't know
i'm leaning toward
evil mermaid or like goth mermaid
because i really like last year i really
got into the whole
um i was watching like all these
halloween makeup tutorials like where
they were doing like all these really
cool scales and [ __ ] like that like on
their faces and i'm like man that looks
pretty cool
it's like i wonder if i could do
something like that so i don't know i'll
see what i looked up some like skirts
and dresses and stuff like that that
were
mermaidy
but i don't know
i don't know i'll see that's what i'm
leaning toward unless i can think of
something better like i said my
one of my um dream halloween costumes
but i don't
this would have to be like custom made
because
no one would know what it was but me
was i wanted to be that like chick from
dagon like the movie you know what i
mean that was in like the wheelchair and
she had the tentacles and she had like
that with that gold
weird crown and [ __ ]
and i kind of wanted to do that but so i
was kind of looking into that but i was
like man i would have to have everything
like made specifically
and
then i'd have to figure out like i'd
have to get a wheelchair i'd have to
like you know
i don't know if i was going to a
convention i'd probably spend the money
on it but
i'd have to get somebody to make that
crown for me because i don't think i
could make that
you know
trust us dress up as lydia from
beetlejuice i've thought about doing
that because and you can actually buy
that's a pretty easy costume to get hold
of yeah
like that red wedding dress
um that's pretty easy to get hold of and
honestly i could just do her hair with
my regular ass hair i can just tease it
like i normally do uh just like i did
brad at frankenstein i didn't even need
a wig for that [ __ ] i just teased my own
hair and like put some white hair spray
on the side uh you know so i have
thought about doing that too but
i don't know i just
something about like the i don't know
maybe i'm kind of feeling like the
mermaid fish person
thing this year because i really want to
do those scales and i just really like
and man i was looking at like some
like headdresses and stuff like some
people had made on etsy they're super
expensive obviously because they're
handmade but they somebody had made like
these really cool like gothic head
dresses but they were like gothic
mermaid ones so they were kind of like
they had horns but then they also had
like all these weird like seashells and
[ __ ] like that all over and i'm like man
that's so [ __ ] cool it's like
but you know i i'm not paying like 500
for a
costume but they it was cool looking
now in case you guys didn't know thanks
i do coach bee's nest in there
i'll coach him online
got him hooked up on trt
walk him through all that he's got a
good doctor
he just got access to a gym because he
moved and this place has a gym
and uh
i could do it through instant messaging
streaming and stuff
if any of you guys need coaching you can
just come to me [ __ ] he pays me
though
but we can work something out
all right a lot of us he paid me a super
chat some of it and [ __ ] sends gifts
and [ __ ]
but if anybody needs training or
online personal training i can do it
sesame says is american halloween like
how the movies make it look
as in are all of the houses heavily
decorated i've always been so jealous
yeah um halloween is a massive
deal
halloween it's people spend almost as
much at halloween actually maybe it
might have gone over christmas now
uh so much so if you go on youtube like
i said i really like this channel called
jade the libra
and but there's several other channels
doing this there's a whole youtube
subculture
of
people who love halloween so much that
as soon as the stores start putting
halloween [ __ ] out which is usually like
late august or early september like
right after the back to school [ __ ]
um they will start going to all of the
stores like michael's joanne fabrics all
that kind of stuff and will show you
like all of the halloween [ __ ] that they
have and they'll be like and this is the
same [ __ ] that they had last year but
look they have this new stuff and it's
just like you said what i mean and it's
like people watch that and then they'll
buy some [ __ ] and they'll have a haul
and then they'll like decorate their
house and everything but uh yeah
halloween is a massive massive deal um
mostly
i kind of feel like people still
trick-or-treat like kids still
trick-or-treat especially in this
neighborhood um we didn't get a lot last
year we got a few
but um we've always had quite a few kids
trick-or-treating in this neighborhood i
kind of feel like it's gone more toward
like parties now um because it almost
seems like it's
you know it for a while when i was
growing up it was mostly just kids like
you know kids would dress up and go
trick-or-treating as i've gotten older
um people are like hey man halloween's
cool like halloween's for everybody not
just for kids so now it seems like more
adults celebrate it you know what i mean
in the sense that they have parties
everywhere every single club has a big
huge
costume contest it's like it's you know
it's it's a huge huge deal so she wants
to go outside okay
thank you zach still thinking it'd be
funny as uh for halloween you guys went
as non-goth regular people because
what's yeah well
i think we told this story before but
shauna who's been on this show before
one year for halloween it was a couple
years two or three years ago i feel like
she showed up at the club at the
halloween party dressed like
um i don't even know what i would call
it but it was almost kind of like a like
a regular like old lady like a frumpy
old lady
so she had like blonde curly hair she
had like this really tacky
like
like flowered shirt these kind of big
like polyester slacks and these like
clunky shoes and this big-ass purse and
it was just for a second i didn't
recognize her but then as soon as i like
saw her face and like recognized her i
just died [ __ ] laughing um
i don't know i don't know if i would do
that though because
i
halloween like i like to dress up all
the time because you know what i mean
just goth people just kind of like to
dress up all the time halloween's every
day but halloween you can go all [ __ ]
out man and ever since i was a little
kid
i'm not i've never been into even when i
was little
i've never been into
like little girl halloween costumes like
i never wanted to be like little
princess or nothing like that i always
wanted to be something gross and ugly
um you know what i mean you're late on
that zach
a lot of people do that well i was
telling her about shauna doing it that
year
and it was super funny like her like in
particular if you know her it's like
it's way funnier she dressed up as a
whole black lady
like like something from the 70s
did she have like i feel like she had
like a fat suit on uh she was just her
pants and stuff yeah she just had like
big like they were polyester i think
yeah
pants and the curlers in her hair
and you know
it was funny because if you guys don't
know who shawna is shawna's a really
good looking black chick man [ __ ] god
black chick
she's got a nice figure
but we know her as that and she's got
really cool dreads dreadlocks and [ __ ]
then she shows up just as a frumpy like
i said i didn't recognize lady i didn't
recognize her for like a minute
me and jenny both of the same
[Laughter]
well and she got into it too she even
kind of acted like and it was so it was
like funny that she like really got into
it but like i said knowing that it's
like funnier that she turned up like
that
like i said i never do that though and
it's like and i really don't like you
know how there's always that one person
well it's probably more than one people
but razor blades in the candy is an
urban legend that's an urban myth that
doesn't happen um
the the only time as far as i know the
only time that somebody has died from
eating halloween candy was back in the
60s 50s it was a long time ago
and it was a pixie stick that had poison
in it and the kid's dad had done it so
it wasn't even like a random stranger
so that's that's where that whole myth
came from but um time for me to put to
go straight on full barbarian oh you're
gonna go
you're jumping right to barbarian you're
not even doing the willy wonka talking
about working out so i gotta go straight
[Laughter]
but i do kind of feel like there's
always that one person that does that
real low effort halloween costume don't
they even sell [ __ ] t-shirts at
walmart [ __ ] like that that are orange
and just say this is my halloween
costume man that is so lame
it's like i get it if you get invited to
something at the last minute but it's
like come on come on
also i like i will buy halloween
costumes if i have to
i've always kind of liked
making my own or putting my own together
from different [ __ ]
because i always kind of like to be
something that's not super obvious or
that there's not already a packaged
costume for which is really hard to do
nowadays
because man
pretty much every single costume i can
think of i was telling before i wanted
to be that chick from dagon yeah but i
said that whole thing would have to be
custom made and honestly i did a search
the other day and as far as i know and
now somebody's gonna steal my idea but
as far as i know nobody has ever dressed
up as that because i don't see anybody i
see i saw stills from the movie but i
never saw anybody like it dressed up as
out of the costume i don't think people
really know that i don't give a [ __ ] if
people know what they know what it is or
not yeah i just think it'd be a cool
costume he always says that every time i
said will nobody know who that was i
don't give a [ __ ] about other people i
don't give a [ __ ]
though that's what i said you need a
wheelchair you need some tentacles i
think and the crown you would have to
have made because it's not like a
regular crown it's like very
asymmetrical and it's not like
you'd have to make it with like [ __ ]
sculpey or something
david june says biggest low effort
costume is the crow
yeah
i kind of feel like well even back in
the day this was a big problem at goth
clubs and you know it's like a joke
everybody wants to show up as a damn
crow yeah after that movie came out it's
like holy crap like everybody would show
up with that makeup on and be like
don't be that guy come on please
they don't do it anymore
i haven't seen anybody dress like the
crow for a really long time
honestly let me get the what oh here it
is brush brush
this [ __ ] hair brush this [ __ ] here is
for a freaking crystal i got it
do you know what i still remember some
of the best halloween costumes i saw
we were at a halloween party at ibarr
which is now called barbarella again
which is what it used to be called a
long time ago we were there like several
years ago and i think this was the same
year
i saw
two people dressed like
those um
those aliens from sesame street the ones
that go yup yup
aliens yeah uh and they they had made
the whole they were so good it was like
a pink one and a blue one uh you know
they had the googly eyes it was oh they
were so awesome they dress like that and
so those were awesome i still remember
that and i still remember the tiny
little
girl the little goth chick who dressed
like adam ant
she had made the jacket she had the you
know she had the war paint like from
goody two shoes from the goodie two
shoes video man she looked so good she
was like 18 or something where was this
at i bar this is like a few years ago
yeah
it was just and she just looked great it
looked exactly exactly like that but
that i still remember those yippie of
aliens because i just i saw that and i
just like laughed my ass off i'm like oh
my god that's so awesome it looks like a
little this says i look like [ __ ]
ozzy i was born in this week you do
like stealing my [ __ ] hair brush she
can't even get it i need that
i might have you need that
i may have to brush
i don't wear this [ __ ] to the club
you should yeah you look like um who is
it that i'm trying to think of who's the
leader
yeah that's her that's that's he knew
exactly how i was talking about love in
you
what's up
loving the dead
loving you is like loving the dead
yeah you look a lot like that dude with
that wig on that's it that's that's who
i was trying to think of when you first
put that wig on it's like you don't look
like ozzy osbourne you don't look like
you don't look like ian asberry you look
like that dude from typo negative
rozzy rosborne
[Laughter]
that's what you look like
uh have you considered dr frankenstein
and elvira or conan and red sonja
some people have said
uh yeah maybe i could do all viral i
guess that'd be pretty easy i got boobs
and everything yeah he could do the
environment that would be pretty easy
and i actually even have like a dress
that's kind of like that
so just gotta get the wig i would just
need a wig and do the uh but like i said
it seems it seems like cheating it seems
like cheating yeah
[Laughter]
stuff like that it just seems like
cheating
i don't i don't know it's
if if it's something that i already have
in my closet then it's like
cheating
little wolf skin boots
and clove cigarettes
an erotic fume funeral
is which she is dressed right
so you're just gonna sit there and brush
your hair the whole time no don't fix it
it's like asm it's like asmr now yeah
hair brushing well you fix one side and
then the other side is all like poofing
out oh this side no the other side yeah
i do i do that too yeah
i'm always like those on the wrong side
of my thing because i'm looking at the
screen
there you go
where to [ __ ] the mannequins
yeah you should
be funny
whatever i betcha i betcha tina wouldn't
recognize me no she probably wouldn't
i think
last last friday we didn't go but last
friday they had uh the gothic beauty
pageant um
this friday i think
this is like this is out there the theme
they had this friday was night of the
cryptids
and i'm not sure i think it's because
it's it was paul van's birthday
um and maybe he's really into bigfoot i
don't i don't know but um
yeah they they wanted uh that was the
same night of the cryptid so i don't
know if everybody's just supposed to
dress up like like your favorite cryptid
like i was supposed to show up like
looking like mothman or
the jersey devil or whatever i don't
know
they've gotten all into themes which is
good because i get a lot of flyer work
you know because they want to do a
different theme every week
but that's fine with me but
peter steele that's what the dude's
that's his name i knew i knew what his
name was but i just couldn't think of it
yeah october race says punk mermaid i
was that they actually do sell
i don't know if i like it or not though
i haven't decided
they do sell like a goth mermaid dress
but it's like a goth skeleton mermaid so
it's like a dress
and the bottom of it has like a mermaidy
type skirt like that kind of goes out at
the end but but then it's like bone so
it's like fish bones
so it's like it's kind of cool but i
can't decide if i like it or not i'm
very ambivalent about it
and then i'm just kind of like i don't
know i kind of like the more traditional
mermaid look but not
green
you know what i'm saying
i don't know
it would be cool if i could get like a
traditional mermaid
outfit but black or black and blue like
shimmery that would be cool
i've seen ones like that on etsy but
they're super expensive because like i
said they're handy peggy pig assist uh
jenny you'd make a good xena warrior
princess she would actually and tom
flocka seagal's t-shirt is c-series
hilarious yeah yeah flock of cigars
flakka cigals like i said i think i got
him that for christmas last year i got
him that one and i got him a coney and
the barbarian one
that said something about you know
too big though the lamentation i think
it was a little too big i got a medium
though does it mean it's maybe just like
all your other shirts
but it depends on the kind of shirt
because i've i have shirts that say
medium but they feel like they're
largest yeah i've gotten mediums before
too and i'm like holy jesus christ is
this like a [ __ ] tent
i will almost always especially if it's
a man's t-shirt because i like
girl fit t-shirts right
um and i'll usually get a small in those
unless they're like hey this shit's like
super tiny because i did get a t-shirt
one time and they said hey this is
pretty small but i got a small anyway
and it fits but
it's pretty tight
so i don't wear it all that much it's
like like i said i still wear it it's
not embarrassing or anything but
but then sometimes if it's a man's shirt
like they because this here's the shitty
thing i hate that
they have a t-shirt like in any shirt
site you go to jiffy shirts or whatever
you buy them like the men's shirt is
like the unisex is considered unisex
like the women's ones are like special
you're trying to make people feel
special
i guess i don't know it's just a pain in
that [ __ ] is a mint shirt because a man
because a man's shirt fits totally
different yeah and i don't like the way
they fit
they don't fit right on a woman and a
lot of times and a lot of times
especially like a lot of band t-shirts
or like a lot of horror t-shirts if i'm
shopping for those they don't have like
woman sizes no and i don't like the way
like i get a man's one and it's small
but it still fits weird i don't like the
way they fit even if a girl's flat
chested the men's t-shirts does not fit
they don't fit right
because they just go straight down
straight down there and i'm like hey
that's not how my body goes they don't
have enough
even a flat-chested woman doesn't have
enough upper body
they don't have enough shoulder width
and stuff for those shirts
girls
get girls shirts they look so much
they're so much better looking on a
woman
well they actually like kind of
yeah and i like that better
yeah i don't like the i don't like the
men's fit
i'll get it if i really really like the
design and they don't have women's just
which an alarmingly lot of like
you know sites that have like horror
t-shirts that i'm not naming any but
like that have horror t-shirts and stuff
and band t-shirts a lot an alarming
amount of them do not have
women's shirt sizes yeah they only have
men's shirt sides which they consider
unisex but i'm like they're totally not
the men's shirts don't fit right is
bee's nest still in there he had to go
to the gym
he was going to hit the gym tonight he
said i'll be out of here in about an
hour he's
i
if i wasn't doing the show i'd [ __ ]
stream with him so i could see what he's
doing because he's going to do something
damn
dumbbell press on the bench
he's working with dumbbells
which you can do it but
best way is [ __ ] with
olympic bar
and an easy crowbar
but now for you guys that were asking
questions about it earlier i think
that's mr roboto
if you need a trainer man i can do
online training and i don't cost that
much but i can walk you through it
go ahead
camp guy says use a black wetsuit and
paint with green scales attach a tail on
wheels
that actually might work um i kind of
like the skirt thing better because they
have like a lot of skirts that look like
a tail on the bottom but you can still
kind of walk in it
um so i like that i just haven't found
one in a pattern that i like but that is
actually a good idea
like to do that with the [ __ ] mermaid
[ __ ] i don't know like i said i haven't
decided if that's what i want to do
but i was gonna say something else about
mermaids but now i can't think of what
it was
god damn it
[ __ ] black wetsuit
this is what happens when you get old
kids can't
he can't [ __ ] remember [ __ ] anymore
no somebody said something uh in it oh
oh i remember what it was october raid
said i'm always too scary for kids to
get candy
um
one year this was before i met you i
think
i don't think they sell these anymore
because i googled them not too long ago
and i couldn't find one one year several
years ago
at
uh spirit halloween or maybe it's target
or something like that they were selling
these sort of like masks but they were
they were already made but they were
latex and you could kind of like cut
them to your face and then you could
paint them yourself like the way you
wanted them they had a skull one a devil
one and a which one so they had like
three different ones and i was like wow
man these are like pretty cool they were
like really nice they were like really
sculpted and they weren't all that
expensive so i got a which one
and you know i it came with like the
latex the liquid latex like the glue and
everything so you could cut it like to
fit your face so i put it on there and i
painted it and then i had like a witch
hat and i had this really old like uh
like lace dress that i bought at like a
thrift store or something and that [ __ ]
looked
amazing that looked like my real [ __ ]
face and i think that that mask was like
five bucks i mean i had to paint it it
took a long time
but
but that's why it reminded me because
it's like i sat up on the porch in a
rocking chair like at my house with a
big bowl full of candy and some kids
would come up there and as soon as they
saw me they were like nope they just
like ran back down because i was just
sitting up there going like that
santa just showed up what's up zaneta
did the dissipater show up
standard is building a dissipator from a
psa upper for you guys that know what
i'm talking about you know what i'm
talking about i got a psa upper two
dissipator i got a bunch of psas and a
bunch of other [ __ ] that i built
but i can um yeah
the
the dissipator was the same one that
emel used during the [ __ ] la [ __ ]
shootout
hugging um xanada bought one of those
uppers
he's waiting on it to show up just
didn't know if it showed up he said not
yet not now yeah okay for another week
or two all right yeah
dissipators are cool you're gonna like
that man you're gonna like it especially
with that hollison on it and an a2 rear
you'll like it or not excuse me a4 rear
sight
it's good
you'll be able to play with it we'll
talk about it later
beowulf said after this show's over i'm
gonna watch either return of the living
dead three or tourist trap just saying
tourist trap's a good man tourist trap
is so good well i think like a couple of
somebody uh your willy wonka slash
michael kane wigs some people have
called that your mr slauson wig like
from tourist traffic which it does kind
of look like that
i feel like taurus trap is like super
super underrated i think that was one of
the first
movies that we did a retrospective on
yeah
it was a pretty lovely one yeah we did
it it was one of the first well i don't
know if it was one of the first ones but
maybe in the first ten that we did very
underrated movie it's super creepy um
i would put it up there with another on
on um
with another underrated classic
that wasn't as underrated as i thought
it was as time went on that was fun
house
yeah i saw a fun house when it came out
me and a lot of other guys
toby hooper i thought it was like a lost
classic and [ __ ] unknown then it
turned out no there's a lot of people
that liked funhouse i [ __ ] loved that
yeah like i said yeah
beezness is asking about the skull i
guess you weren't here when i showed it
yeah we already talked about skull yeah
i showed it and i was like yeah this is
badass in case you guys didn't see it
look at it
business he's going to say he's going to
send us something else like that
and he's looking [ __ ] cool he's got
to [ __ ] see no evil here no evil do
no evil and i was saying no i said jenny
likes these [ __ ]
dia de los muertos skulls
yeah you can bring more of these skulls
i love all that kind of well anything
yeah
i'm pretty easy honestly i mean not in
that way but you know what i mean
i like dia de los muertos stuff i like
edgar allan poe stuff yeah i like any
kind of [ __ ] i like halloween [ __ ]
yeah
says american halloween you saw that
through through um the eyes of hollywood
out in california
one that you don't know is mexican
halloween mexicans halloween is a lot
different than ours but it's [ __ ]
really cool super goth too being a black
metal check you'd like it
you can go online
and go look look up a friend of mine
voltaire he's [ __ ] one of my
my friend tanya's ex-boyfriend or
ex-husband was voltaire he's a [ __ ]
goth
he's a musician
and he does [ __ ] he did a show about the
goth scene in mexico did you watch it no
you were telling but i was telling you
about it and [ __ ] he'll show you all
kinds of cool [ __ ] that they have in
mexico that's gothic all right and one
of the things that they have is this dia
de los muertos is their version of
[ __ ]
halloween all right
it was if
the aesthetic is very good it's very
victorian spanish
with a mesoamerican influenced aztec
influence to it is [ __ ] it's
beautiful
it's it's a uniquely mexican and uh it's
a uniquely mexican excellence
um
it was so good cool that they put that
[ __ ] in a james bond movie that was in
uh
inspector specter opens up with him in
mexico city dear indeed it is de los
muertos romance and this mexican girl
and then
dumps her to go off and pull a [ __ ]
mission assassinate some dude and knock
over like just knock over a whole
[ __ ] building and [ __ ] didn't make so
much property but it's um
a lot of people in the english-speaking
hem world
don't realize how victorian and how
gothic
central and south american stuff is
okay
it's a big [ __ ] goth scene all
throughout central and south america
lots of [ __ ] catholic [ __ ] tombs
and graveyards
um colombia has a lot of it
um
central
growing up in south america you'll know
that south americans and central
americans really like visual stuff
handmade stuff and they love drama
and there's a lot of theatrics and a lot
of drama in the goth scene that
central and south americans pick up on
they really like it
well there's a massive goth scene in
south america yeah brazil
specifically yeah it's still growing
strong there it might be and there's not
here but it's strong down there i don't
even i don't know i wouldn't even say it
was played out here because it's still
pretty big here
but in south america um mexico has a
really big uh god scene like i said the
i told him about this so you know i'm i
really like voltaire and he has a little
show a little channel on youtube called
the lara voltaire it's mostly he does
gothic homemaking like he shows you how
to you know he does diy projects and he
shows how to like decorate your house
like in gothy ways he also does
halloween halls like where he goes to
different stores and shows all their
halloween
decor and stuff like that
um but he had one
where he went to mexico city
and well he's cuban right yeah i think i
think he's cuban um so he went to mexico
city and went to like pretty much all
the goth haunts there like he went to
all the stores and he went to like all
the bars and coffee houses he's like
there's like three
which witch-themed coffee houses like
within like a few blocks and [ __ ] like
there's like a werewolf one there's like
all kind of like cool monster [ __ ] and
it's cool because a lot of the um
the stores there that sell gothic
clothing because it's so expensive to
import it from the us or from uh europe
most of the stores there like is one
person
that runs it and also makes all the
clothes like they make and they design
and make their own clothes
noticed that a lot of the goth rock
music videos and songs on youtube have
spanish subtitles available yeah they
all want to know what that stuff says
you know what i mean um
i would say europe is probably the
leader in goth music
and the leader of the fat in in fashion
but central and south america takes what
they see
from
northern culture and they're going to
put a [ __ ] central and south american
spin on it it looks cool as [ __ ] grab
that [ __ ] skull again show them that
their version of goth it comes out like
this and
i i i respect it
well dia de los muertos has really taken
off in the u.s in the last few years
because even if you go um to
somewhere like um i can't remember if
it's michael's or somewhere around like
some big chain
there they have um a whole line of
halloween decor that's all dia de los
muertos and day of the dead yeah in case
you don't understand what it is but
that's their version of halloween and
they've kind of conflated that with
spooky gothiness
and uh yeah they they put their own spin
on it and uh
up here in the north we're appreciating
it we're vibing it we're like yeah
that's it
it's just kind of like how long did it
take for us to like twig onto that and
it took us forever to twig onto that and
it took us forever to get onto the whole
krampus train right because i feel like
i wish that had caught on earlier i it
feels like just the last few years that
everybody finally caught onto krampus
how [ __ ] cool that is because you
know regular christmas shit's kind of
lame but man christmas demon yeah you
signed me up for that [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
yeah mexican goth and central american
goth yeah
that works
they understand it
they they took it they [ __ ] spun it
and [ __ ] threw it right back at us
they're like okay yeah made it
accessible product and what i do like
about the mexican and central american
goth scene is that it's it's not
corporate
all their [ __ ] is handmade
including their clothes
yeah that's what and i liked that uh
that voltaire went to like two or three
different stores and the stores that he
went to all the guys that ran it were
the same people that made and design and
like made all the clothes like designed
and made all the clothes yeah cause they
said you know it's not worth it to like
import all the [ __ ] so it's just easier
for us to like make and so it's like one
guy and his mom and they're just like in
the back of the store like making all
the [ __ ] like on one sewing machine and
it's better that it's it that they're
doing it through their cultural [ __ ]
lens
like
the opposite would be japan japan just
straight-ups copies everything that they
see
they don't put a japanese-ness to it
oh you know what i mean like you can see
goth industrial in japan but they don't
listen to the music but they're wearing
those exact same fashions over and over
and over again
but there isn't a japanese form of it
they see it as something that's foreign
and they an exotic and they keep it for
an exotic they don't make their own
version of it
which that's the mexicans do it oh no we
have that this is our version of it and
boom there it is well that's kind of the
thing and i'm not [ __ ] on like goth
lolita is what is mainly what you're
talking about or like the what do they
call it harajuku or whatever they call
it yeah yeah
still western but the thing about i love
the lolita look yeah but
it's kind of like it was kind of a thing
like i feel like maybe in the 90s or
early 2000s like everybody was going
goth lolita but the thing about it was
the look was the only goth thing about
it they didn't listen to any music that
the that goth people here would
recognize and it wasn't japanese that's
not a japanese outfit that's a western
outfit that's not the japanese outfit
would have been a couple yeah a lot of
it's like victorian it's victorian
all right a japanese version would be
kimonos and kabuki masks and things like
that
which how badass would that be that
would be much better that's the way an
american would do it from a japanese
perspective but the japanese one didn't
do it that way i mean like i said i like
that look i even had like a couple
dresses like that but
um but goth lolita it was just a fashion
movement it wasn't
other than just surface stuff it wasn't
really i didn't really tie it in with
like the goth
subculture because i think well because
it was just fashion they didn't have
anything they didn't know anything about
the music or anything like that they
just like the this one particular look
of the clothing which is fine people can
wear whatever they want
i'm just saying that i think people like
roped it in with the god subculture and
it wasn't exactly the same
you did see
um
probably like in the early i want to say
it was probably like the early 2000s
maybe late 90s you did see some people
kind of go in and like hear dressing in
that little bit more lolita direction
um you don't see it much anymore
but it was kind of a thing for a hot
minute
but like i said it's
it was just a fashion thing for them
they didn't really
they didn't really like listen to the
music or know anything about the back
you know they weren't like [ __ ]
reading
charles baudelaire or
listening to susie the banshees or
anything like that it was just kind of
like they just liked the clothes i guess
but uh you know
yeah uh
yeah
were you the one that said something
about edward uh paisnell the beast of
jersey yeah i wrote that down i'll put
that in for for a topic at some point
yeah see
the the whole idea of crap and you know
don't get me wrong i love christmas okay
i love christmas i like all that candy
cane [ __ ] i like snowman i like all that
kind of [ __ ]
but
i really i don't know why it took us so
long
to get on board with the whole krampus
thing because how [ __ ] cool is that
that is so cool it's like because
without that it just seems like you
don't have that cool scary spooky
element
you know i kind of feel like in
i was is it in italy where they have the
christmas witch is she called belfana
befana something like that
i kind of feel like i read about that
um
so i feel like most other cultures
have like
a creepy
you know aspect to christmas whereas you
know i feel like you know in the uk
particularly not so much nowadays but
like back in the victorian era like
christmas was like ghost story time and
i was like man we need some [ __ ] like
that over here christmas just like oh
yay everything's happy and twinkly and
it's like
you know
that's fine but
i like creepy [ __ ] you know what i mean
there needs to be a creepy aspect to
every single holiday otherwise i can't
enjoy it but yeah so
i don't know we don't we don't even have
like creepy aspects of like easter or
anything like that other than the
[ __ ] that weird resurrection stuff
but yeah so i it's funny because i
actually did for mannequins
they're doing like i mentioned before
they're um they're really getting
excited about doing themes like for
every week
so
i've been doing like a lot of different
flyers all the themes they're coming up
with they want to do a different theme
for every weekend in october
which we'll see how that goes
i've already done
a couple christmas ones i did a
nightmare before christmas poster i did
a krampus poster
um they're also thinking about doing an
elf on the shelf
theme
which in a way might be kind of funny
because that elf on the shelf the whole
concept of the elf on the shelf is
kind of sinister when you think about it
here's this little sh this little elf
and we're putting it and you put it in
your kid's room and he's like this
this elf is watching you
oh yeah super chats i don't think you
read them there's a bunch of them going
way back thank you maddie p have you
ever done a review of phantasm yes we
have we've done phantasm and phantasm
too did we not
i kind of feel like we did both of those
i thought we did the whole series
uh we i we haven't done three through
five but i'm pretty sure we did one and
two we were gonna do three through five
because all the phantasm movies are
worth watching
thank you zach yeah no time to die
finally comes out october 8th oh my god
i can't wait i'm going to be like a
pregnant lady when i see it and cry at
everything ah you do you zack
[Laughter]
i'm actually kind of excited about a lot
of movies coming out that's why i'm glad
we kind of got the amc thing back
plus get us out of the house
yeah try to get me we might go to we
might go to a movie tomorrow if i finish
up all the [ __ ] i was doing
good we were going to go today but i was
kind of busy getting kind of depressed
being in the [ __ ] house all the time
because of this [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
not locked down here it's just that
there's not a whole lot going on that's
it's not like it was
but you know it's like i said i'm
excited about seeing malignant yeah um
[Music]
last night in soho yeah there was
another super chat
zach says no time to die finally comes
out yeah i just read that i
literally read that like 30 seconds ago
okay i was i was well i'm also reading
other [ __ ] too this is what happens when
you don't listen to jenny yeah
from what i've heard unless they fixed
it no time of no time to die sucked i
mean i'm gonna see it
i will see it i mean
the first four movies were great but
evidently they had to fix it
well that doesn't always mean a bad
thing like because sometimes in you know
sometimes i go see a movement like wow
that was [ __ ] great and then i do
like research on it and they're like oh
man we didn't think this when we had to
cut it all up and take it back and blah
blah blah mango said that [ __ ] fun
house is a great movie makes a very good
double bill with my bloody valentine yes
yeah yeah
and also um terror train
yeah those two those two seem like they
would go good too we just did a review
of terror train too not too long ago
awesome just got back i see tom with a
danzig wig he must be sauced yeah i'm
sauced
yeah you're on your third one already
i've even got through my second one
usually i'm ahead of you but
uh tom jenny won't do a drive go to a
drive-in movie do we have any driving
tower i don't think we have any
drive-ins around here
you couldn't do it here in the south
because uh the heat
you had to run your car all the time for
air conditioning
and or you'd get eaten alive yeah
mosquitoes and horse flies
i think i got bit by a horse fly the
other day actually
i woke up the other day and had this
horrible like red welt on my finger
october race said your face is very
beautiful jim
thank you yeah oh see i didn't see that
mr roboto ad says steven seagal i think
he wears a lot of black no he is not
gothic [ __ ] is a poser
just wearing black doesn't make you yeah
he's not even a martial artist well he's
a martial artist but he doesn't
he
that's not a real martial he's a
marshmallow artist yeah yeah
yeah see what i did there
[ __ ] he made good soft drinks though
asian experience is [ __ ] fantastic
from what i understand
and if you swim in a pool
rather than drinking i love it
with a beautiful amerasian [ __ ] you
know hapa [ __ ]
model will come in and [ __ ] get in
your pool a [ __ ] asian that
commercial makes me laugh and throw up
in my mouth at the same time you guys
can google the commercial on youtube
it's the asian experience steven seagal
energy drink commercial
where he's out there [ __ ] at the side
of his pool
and he does have this [ __ ] beautiful
hapa
[ __ ] that got hired for the
commercial she's being paid
she's not there through her volition
a hopping was an old school term
probably maybe youngsters know what it
is it's like half a m half asian half
european yeah is that still in you
because i had a i have a friend
uh i haven't talked to him in a few
years but he's half he was half japanese
and he used that term but i don't know
if that's really i don't know about it
today one of my first big crushes out in
california when i was a [ __ ]
what was cr christina toy
and her dad owned the barn where i kept
my pony
he owned the [ __ ] barn there he was
japanese and he married a
uh because california used to have a big
japanese population of immigrants that
moved therefore well still does as far
as i think they moved back most of them
um
he married this blonde american woman
and had christina and and me and chris
me and christy kind of
grew up together in the [ __ ] when the
horse scene when we were kids she was
only like a year older than me
but um she ended up being one of the
beauty queens of my my military academy
because they were looking for beauty
queens and [ __ ] to go through these
ceremonies and they had like five of
them and i got her in my old yearbook
and [ __ ] christy was [ __ ] cute as
[ __ ] she was hapa
and um i don't know whatever happened to
her
but i'll show i'll show her to you never
seen christy have you i don't think so i
don't think you've ever what's funny is
that when you're 14 or when you're 13 or
14
and a boy
a girl that's a year older than you
looks five years older than you well
girls
mature much quicker right yeah
yeah i remember that too because i
remember being in middle school in high
school right and like some of the boys
even though they're the same age
looked like children right yeah and all
the girls look like [ __ ] young women
yeah i had a huge crush on her but uh
she didn't really notice me in that way
of course because you know what i mean
because you're a chief you're a child
you're a 13 year old boy you're a child
and you're 13 or 14 year old girl i
think she was 14. looks like a young
woman you know yeah [ __ ] i had boobs
when i was in fifth grade they're more
looking at guys who are like [ __ ] 18
20. that's what they're looking at yeah
yeah they don't like i said it's yeah
and you know universe well and the thing
about it too is that you know no offense
but dudes take not not only a lot longer
to physically mature but a lot longer to
mental images oh the mental maturity is
a big difference um so
so a lot of dudes like legit do seem
like children yeah even if they're the
same age as you are yeah um so that's
why a lot of girls go for older ones
especially at that age yeah
at that age there's a huge difference it
yeah there really is tammy said i needed
to make a t-shirt that says this is what
happens when you don't listen to jenny
jenny's the voice of reason but the
world is not a reasonable place i've
seen some weird ass [ __ ] man [ __ ]
i've been involved in some weird ass
[ __ ] where reason would have failed me
thinking it's
[Laughter]
because other [ __ ] are not
reasonable
you can't well it depends on who you're
talking about doesn't it
evil and violent men are not reasonable
so you can't well done you can't use
some reason with them i wasn't gonna try
to yeah right you can't use reason with
them you can't expect them to be
reasonable yeah but see the thing about
reasonable people is that they when is
that the reason that they're reasonable
is because they know when reasons that's
granters that's granters he made a whole
living with the police force of dealing
with [ __ ]
evil men they're not reasonable they
wouldn't be evil if they were reasonable
santa said didn't women used to get
married at age 15 in the 1800s early
earlier
um as soon as uh as soon as you started
uh waiting 13 12 and could get pregnant
then they're like hey
get out
you can start making babies
i mean in the 90s when i got out of the
army and moved back to mississippi
the age of consent was 13.
yeah in 96.
okay
[ __ ] 14 year old girls would [ __ ]
make a hit on you trying to get laid
because they were married by 16 17 most
of them
they lived a lot faster back then
and um just it's just not though it's
not the same world
well and you know depending on
because i think the thing that happened
back in the day especially in like kind
of isolated rural communities yeah they
all went to each other
one they all knew each other and two
girls are just trying to get the [ __ ]
out of their parents house you don't
want to be in your parents house you
want to start your life get the [ __ ] out
of there they didn't have to know that
much either it was a very low-tech
society it was just how to grow food how
to wash things how to [ __ ] plant a
little bit of [ __ ] farm outside the
back of your house there wasn't uh an
idea careers even the men didn't really
have careers
that wasn't something that they had
it was just survival
yeah it's like now you kind of have to
know
everything right you kind of have to
know how to do everything yeah you
didn't really
[Laughter]
which you didn't really have to back
then so in a lot of ways it's kind of
like it was easy it was easier to be a
smart person back then because it was a
lot less information there's a lot less
knowledge out there right so it's like
you just knew this little bit nobody's
like oh my god he's a [ __ ] genius
yeah
uh well look
in the 1700s
when first of all the only people that
went to colleges and universities were
very rich kids
and they were all
had a religious slant
and when you got a degree from a place
like you know harvard or wherever you
know you basically knew the sum of all
human knowledge
in the 1700s like all these founding
fathered guys you know what i mean from
the 1700s they all had the exact same
education they knew a little bit about
everything they weren't specialists they
were generalists
but they also knew a lot of scripture
and
a man could learn the sum of all human
knowledge back then there wasn't very
much
it wasn't very much that's what i was
saying right so much easier right in a
way i think it made better people though
in some ways because they were all
generalists they could do a little bit
of everything
specialization i think uh limits people
because you only see the world through
the lens of your specialty
but the thing about it is that there's
we're so aware of how much knowledge
there is out there that it's like you
almost have to specialize because if you
try to like learn something about
everything you die before you learned it
all yeah the problem is is that every
[ __ ] educated specialist has
his own opinion and it's
a lot of times wrong because it's only
from
a very small point of view
but it doesn't matter anymore in a
certain way because we're now definitely
an ant colony
and everybody shuts the [ __ ] up and you
do your little part of it even though
that's starting to break down because ai
and internet is now getting and getting
in the way of all that
i just saw a program on it [ __ ]
yesterday
about the education system in the united
states including the uh university
system
and they're talking about how it's just
failing a lot of
a lot of the colleges are kind of
[ __ ] empty um and it's just because
you spend a lot of money on this
education and you won't get a job
and the education that they're giving
you really doesn't fit what the job
market is anymore
um
because technology is just [ __ ] just
decimated the job market
everybody's doing what we're doing
basically
where you're just trying to survive over
the internet and new sources of income
and a bun everybody is totally just
diversified and has more than one income
stream
uh then that's kind of the way it's
going it's because
corporations aren't hiring people just
not what it was
you know and i mean honestly it's kind
of like
it's a pain and like i said i work every
day like you know i don't i don't have
days off i don't even on days we don't
stream i'm still doing other things like
i'm still recording i'm still writing
i'm still doing work for other people
but
what i was gonna say
was that um
as hard as it is and as stressed out as
i get sometimes and as tired as i get
um if somebody came to me and said hey i
pay you x amount of dollars to go back
to like a nine-to-five job where you're
working for somebody else i would
totally not do it no no way well that's
that's what i was gonna say
um at least you're not working for
somebody else that's what i'm saying
getting all the damn profits
we're doing basically what
the very beginnings of immediate
medieval capitalism was after the
[ __ ]
black plague had [ __ ] annihilated
everyone
the serfs were all freed from the land
and everybody stayed at home and made
things and sold them in the town square
we're doing very much of that right now
basic but the town square today is the
internet
yeah but that's what we're doing
uh this is the beginnings that was the
roots of capitalism not corporatism no
no no no
people are
[ __ ] things up they're talking about
these corporations and calling that
capitalism that is not capitalism
if you go back capitalism was peasants
freed from the land
making products inside their cottages
and selling them in the town square that
was the very beginning of capitalism not
corporatism and industrialism that is
very different
that's almost like uh
it's almost kind of like communism but
it's a cult communism it's communism for
only the people inside the corporation
because if you look at marxism and
communism it
basically what that is is reducing the
state into
a corporation
where everybody is a shareholder holder
and an employee of the corporation
there's a no compete clause
so basically we're going back to [ __ ]
crude anarcho-capitalism
what this is
make money how you can survive
which like i said it has its own
drawbacks but
there's freedom honestly i like yeah
that
you know you can go on like i said you
know we need all the infrastructure
obviously because if we didn't have the
internet we'd all be [ __ ] yeah then
but um
right but i like that somebody
you know
is like man you know what i'd really
like to do with my life i'd really like
to make weird like taxidermy sculptures
oh you'd make them money but
yeah and then like you make them and you
go on etsy and you can sell each one for
like a few hundred dollars and you can
maybe make a living at that and it's
just kind of like that's pretty cool i
mean
i used to love to make models jenny
bought me a model of star trek starship
enterprise i'm getting together all the
paintings yeah the big one with the
lights in it i used to love making
models
when i was a kid back when my vision was
super good now i'm gonna need a big old
magnifying glass probably to do i'm
getting the same i can't see [ __ ] um
they got guys that sit around and make
those models
and then they put
lights in them and
customize lights and light features on
remotes
and then they'll sell those models after
they make them
so they'll make them for people and they
make a lot of [ __ ] money well yeah
like you know dude goes i want this
model it's the 650 1650 scale
enterprise but i want the deluxe
lighting i want this and that and i want
it to be painted up
presentation bad as a [ __ ] on a
remote and this and that they got guys
i'll go i can do that and he'll spend
a month
making that [ __ ] model and he's
making other ones too because he's got
more than one custom customers
and he'll take that 200 model kit
and [ __ ] sell that thing for a
[ __ ] 1300 bucks to some dude
who really wants that model
well yeah like i said it's very it's
easy to target yeah uh your audience
nowadays so like i said i've you know
i've been watching a lot of like
voltaire's [ __ ] and he uh goes to a lot
of different places and you know he'll
say if he got something from an etsy
shop or yeah whatever and it's just kind
of like if every time i see that it like
makes me so happy
that somebody is making maybe making a
living just making this creepy gothy
[ __ ] that they like and they're enjoying
making it yeah and they've you know and
enough people heard about it that they
can maybe make a living at it or at
least make like some extra money
uh beowulf said that english film when
the lights went out is based on the
infamous black monk of pontefract is a
really good modern haunted house film
i've actually been wanting to see that
because we did a show about the black
monk not too long ago and i saw that
that film was out and i saw some clips
from it and it looked really good but it
was hard for me to get uh but now that i
have vpn maybe it's like easier for me
to hey dimitri's hair oh dimitri what's
up
what's up we just saw you yeah
dj maniac says tom knows i'm a kit bash
or he's seen some of my work yeah i
don't just do it for profit though see
that but that's awesome it's it's like
if you wanted to make money from it you
could though and i think that's like
really cool like i said it's you know
and i've said this before it makes me so
happy that even though
obviously i'm not getting rich off [ __ ]
you know i make enough to pay my bills
and that's about it but
you know it's so cool that if i wanted
to like i can design board a board game
that i want and i have like you know a
platform putting that up and it's like i
can do my own books and i can do the
layout and [ __ ] like that and it's like
there's
you know an audience out there for that
like i said i'm not gonna be stephen
king rich from the [ __ ] but beowulf18
said did tom and jenny see conjuring
three yet if so did you like it i have
not seen it was in the theater right now
um no well that was a little bit back
okay i saw the first conjuring which was
okay the second conjuring was based on
enfield i thought
right
we also saw la la rona wasn't that from
that scenario
yeah that was that from the same thing
yeah it's the same universe
yeah thank you no need for me to can't
stay just wanted to say hi and send my
best regards thank you very much super
busy as of late with packing away my dad
stuff sell his house stay creepy and
weird oh we will don't you guys tell me
sometimes it's hard to find the clients
that pay for that work that's true it is
yeah that's well because they're so
that's that's the downside is there's so
much competition out there you see the
thing is is that and this is my
experience as a as a corporate salesman
before the internet ever really existed
a lot of sales has to do with
personality and pr
now that you have social media you have
to be a social media
phenomenon a person known in social
media in order to sell
something like model works you'd have to
have a channel on youtube that does
reviews on models and then you show your
own work a good example would be ethan
van sciver he worked corporate wise for
marvel and
did comic books he went solo
and became a [ __ ] great host so he
had kind of a built-in audience yeah he
that's that helps he built an audience
just talking about comic books and then
he says i'm gonna make my own new comic
book company of
custom comic books and [ __ ]
everybody's raising money and he and
he's talking about who's going to do the
art who's going to do the [ __ ] story
writing what is it going to be sylvester
stallone got involved they did like one
of an expendables version
or an expendables comic book called
expendables go to hell where they
actually do go to hell and fight the
devil
and uh okay i'd watch that they went on
kickstarter and they're raising hundreds
of thousands of dollars before they even
start making the goddamn comic book
it was because he was a
social media phenomenon
and then he started the company
yeah like i said it helps to have that
built-in fan base so that you have i
mean you know there's a reason why
when mystery science theater went on
kickstarter they made like seven million
dollars is because everybody already
knows that problem so hugo if you're big
into models and kit and mango badger kit
bashing what you do is you start off
with your own channel that talks about
models and kit bashing
you do reviews on models then you show
them you talk about models
do live streams and talking about other
geeky nerdy [ __ ] nerd the [ __ ]
out on the fine details of all these
models
and then
a year or so into it later on you start
talking about projects that you're gonna
do who's gonna buy them who's gonna fund
it what it is you're gonna make like for
instance you can come out and say i'm
going to make a [ __ ] star wars
y-wing fighter
by hand
out of pieces of damn plastic it's going
to be four feet long
out of cat hair yeah whatever you know
it's going to have everything on remote
control and everything's going to do
everything
who might be interested in that who
wants to raise money for the show we'll
do a whole show on it and people will
probably just send you money to see you
make it for the show
all right then once it's done you can
auction it off or keep it or whatever
you have to make it a show
well you just have to kind of build and
show or you have to build a community or
build a community around it because like
i said that's all people that are into
the same [ __ ] that you're into and so
you know that's how you target your
audience right
more than you know just hey here's the
thing that i have yeah it's not like
buck think because yeah because
everyone's doing that everybody tries to
do that so
you know and and no one's just going to
want to like buy some [ __ ] off some
random [ __ ]
you've already got to be a famous
[ __ ] talking about models and
kid bashing and everything that well you
have to know what you're talking you got
to know you're talking about and you got
to have a bunch of fans
and then you start doing things like i'm
gonna make a model who you know and then
after the model's done who who wants to
buy this model or who wants to fund this
model you know it could be something
like that but it's not something you can
start from zero
you got to have
a fan base it's just like anything else
it takes years you have to like work for
it but years don't years go by fast when
you're our age
yeah yeah
soon you die then you just like tom said
yeah
i said jenny god damn it was three years
ago you know jenny we're gonna die soon
and i said that's the spirit that's the
spirit
camp guy said some of those cooking
dudes on youtube have companies send
them equipment and even meet and stuff
yeah if you get big enough because like
i said you know i talk about jade the
libra a lot but it's like she has
um she does other [ __ ] too like on
instagram
she has like goth clothing companies
send her clothes
they send her like spirit halloween
sends her halloween costumes um just so
she'll do a video like unboxing and like
showing them and stuff
so once you get big enough and you're
considered an influencer then yeah
companies will send you free [ __ ]
uh to make a video about it
which we haven't got to that point yet i
haven't had anybody the only thing
that's had that i've had happen i've had
a few
uh book publishers like contact me and
want to send me like free
copies of their books to review
so but that's as far as it's gone
like i said we're still pulling for that
shutter membership
that shutter sponsorship
but you know what i mean one of these
days understand nobody's honestly if
like somebody wanted to send me some
free [ __ ] like some company wanted to
send me some free [ __ ]
yeah
you know what i would hold on one second
captain blair just said if i had the
money i would buy a light up model the
constitution class 1701 no refit abd
serum
or maybe a bloody d or whatever or a c
what i was thinking about doing
jenny jenny gave me the just the the
original star trek series
[ __ ] enterprise it has all the lights
in it and everything the the uh the
light kit
for it
man i was real tempted to turn that into
the mirror universe [ __ ] uh
iss [ __ ] but the thing is though is
the iss the warping the cells on the
on the top the the warp nacelles they
weren't clear they were painted bronze
so the lighting effect wouldn't shine
through and it didn't come with the
decals for iss
enterprise i mean i could
probably maybe find some oh i'm sure you
could probably something but i might
have it but
the lighting effects if you need it i
could make them if you wanted me too
i i'm thinking that if i would the first
one to get is the [ __ ] kirk's
enterprise from this universe well
that's what i thought if i was ever
making no yeah if i ever wanted another
[ __ ] enterprise it would be the
mirror enterprise from the original
series that would be cool but after this
one's done what i want is i want a
[ __ ] katinga class [ __ ] klingon
[ __ ] battle cruiser from the original
series see that was that was second on
my list i did have that on my wish list
like i was gonna get that if i couldn't
get it and then a romulan warbird from
the [ __ ] original
which is a little smaller ship i believe
but [ __ ]
we'll see if they have that oh i like
the original series and the movies
yeah the movies with shatner uh um those
are the ones that i'm most i mean i like
them all i don't really like the new
star trek
they were all right but no the new cbs
one that starts oh i haven't seen i
haven't seen that i was talking about
the the what's his name the movie and
i'm gonna [ __ ] say some of the
original series i'm big in the original
series in the original movies i really
liked enterprise too
a lot of people enterprised me i liked
enterprise
better than next generation even though
i liked gender next generation
enterprise is the one with scott bakula
yeah scott bakula is
by the
by the time the [ __ ] second season
third season started
enterprise was [ __ ] really rolling
it did have some problems it kept the
they dropped the ti the the the the time
war
uh aspect they should have kept with
that
but it had one of the best mirror
episodes in a mirror darkly one and two
but uh no i liked it real good
i'm just saying that if you ever need
anything decal related you can do decals
i can do that okay
like as long as you give me the specs
and the sizes and stuff i know i can do
all that all right
i know all about printing and all that
kind of [ __ ]
i can do all that so just let me know
okay
if i ever do another enterprise i'll do
the mirror enterprise which is the
[ __ ] yeah i just have to like measure
i'd have to measure all the
you know all the areas and everything
like that it was a little simplified
uh versus the because
the uss enterprise was [ __ ] more like
a ship of [ __ ]
peace and [ __ ] exploration it did
have some war capabilities but the iss
was [ __ ] totally just war capable
i think you know i mean it didn't it had
armor on it and [ __ ] where where the the
uss didn't have up in the warp desales
and stuff
and i think the colors were more
simplified
yeah yeah it was a warship you know i
can be i can barely remember what what
that was the same it's just the colors
were different yeah
santa said there's a girl i watch who
started by reviewing star wars models
and now she's blown up star wars girl
check her out see that's what i mean all
you need
is you just need to find your niche
because you know there's always people
that are the same weird-ass [ __ ] as you
are like don't be afraid to like geek
out about the [ __ ] like i said millions
of people
will watch a girl
go to joann fabrics and film halloween
decorations okay
millions people will watch that
um you know what i mean so it's just
gonna as long as you have like the
personality and you do it cool and
everything like that and you're like a
likable person
then
tons of people will watch that you have
to think outside the box
uh we're going through a time of [ __ ]
great transition economic transition
um
and societal transition a lot of the
things that you needed
to succeed back in the day you don't
need it anymore
um
internet has a lot to do with it
because money is about getting a product
or a service to a client that's really
all it is
and with the internet that [ __ ] that
makes it a lot easier
you just have to know what it is you're
selling who it is you're selling it to
yeah and you just have to find your
market like i said and don't be afraid
to like be
to target a niche market that's what
everyone's doing nowadays
and that's really how you're gonna like
i said you might not you're probably not
gonna get rich off it
but you might make a living you might
actually be able to make a living off
you know
a few thousand people a few hundred
thousand people if you're lucky
that like the same [ __ ] that you do like
i said don't be afraid to like geek out
about [ __ ] seriously today i randomly
because it was recommended to me
i randomly watched i had never seen this
dude before but it was this dude
um i did like i used to like uh what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is the name of that
podcast
god-awful movies god-awful movies used
to do a podcast they still do it as far
as i know and it's three guys and
they're making fun of like christian
movies and they the shows are long
they're as long as the actual movie
so
because i'm subscribed to that channel i
guess they
you know youtube gave me this other
channel and it was kinda i can't
remember what his name was but he's this
[ __ ] hilarious
like really like over-the-top
gay dude and he
and he like critiques like all these
christian movies and he had done like
god's not dead
and i watched it it was like an hour and
15 minutes long and oh my god i was
dying it was so [ __ ] funny like all
the [ __ ] [ __ ] he was saying and it's
just kind of like so people will watch
whatever mostly i watch i watch
horror channels
um
halloween [ __ ] i love halloween [ __ ]
like all year round if you're like
looking at halloween decorations or
decorating your house for halloween or
whatever
halloween diy making halloween cakes
i'll watch that [ __ ] all year long i
love that [ __ ]
um you know but that's mostly what my
[ __ ] is scary stories i love like all
those kind of scary stories channels
like i said just find something and even
if other people are doing it
it doesn't really matter because
you know you can always put your own
spin on it because for a long time i was
kind of thinking
well
why should i bother like talking about
horror movies because there's
you know x amount of other channels
doing that
but
then i was like well yeah but
that doesn't matter it doesn't matter
there's not like a [ __ ] down it's like
and they're not me so
maybe people will like me better than
the other dude you know what i mean so
you can't think about it too much i
guess
and honestly
there's a lot of horror [ __ ] on
youtube but not as much as you might
think
and honestly sometimes
because sometimes like if i'm doing
research for example
uh for uh you know a movie that we're
reviewing and i was like well i want to
see like what other people think about
this movie so i watch like a [ __ ] ton of
other reviews of it to see other
people's insights about it or whatever
and to be honest the same handful come
up
so the other horror channels must not be
all that big because
he's ready for that i get the cat out
he comes back and i'm like where's my
drink [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's what i thought that's what you
had one job
but yeah so so i kind of feel like the
same
handful of people that come up every
time like i like um
sinister cinema i like that guy
um
i like bloodbath and beyond they're
pretty funny
um
i like cinemassacre although he doesn't
he does horror movies but he mostly does
video games
and um
what else oh you know who i like
i like grumpy andrew
he's a british dude and his channel is
called grumpy andrews
house of horror so it's a guy g-a-h-h
and uh he's super funny and his show is
like super lo-fi it's just like him in
his living room um just like talking
into a phone or whatever but
he's super fun and he's super super
smart and he really likes old
movies like hammer movies and all this
kind of [ __ ] and it's just like he's
really really insightful so i always
watch his [ __ ] about stuff
but yeah he's really cool i like him a
lot
but there's not i mean there's a lot of
horror content but there's not a lot of
good horror content you know what i'm
saying a lot of it's not is real
low rent a lot of it's just like a dude
in his bedroom
with like shittier cameras than we have
and shittier microphones than we have
which makes me feel better
[Laughter]
actually we have better we have a better
camera than that we could be using you
could probably put that on it and use it
i could i really should sort of got a
good [ __ ] camera right there i bought
that one to do pookie videos yeah we
never actually i was gonna give pookie
her whole like side channel yeah not a
side channel but her whole like side
playlist we've never used that [ __ ]
camera that's ridiculous i've used it a
couple of times filming pokey
and beige
i was gonna do like a whole other um
playlist thing called puke and beige
but
most of the time during the day when i'm
filming they're just sleeping
that's not all that exciting how long
we've been streaming
two hours and 43 minutes okay
oliver know what i was thinking about
what i was almost thinking about going
to mannequins tonight
it's wednesday i know
i don't want to go on wednesday what fun
is that just to hang out
they play golf music tonight i don't
know if you want to
yeah german stan oliver harper yeah i
really like oliver yeah i like oliver
harper he's good he kicks us um
i like uh midnight's edge they're really
good because they have a lot of
hollywood insiders come in
um
i like um the horror show
is which is two guys usually sometimes
they have another they have a girl on
there
um trying to think brandon ten old we
brought him up before he's really good
he's a canadian dude he he kind of he's
a real big mystery science theater fan
so he does a lot of like shitty movies
yeah and he'll do like an mst style
commentary yeah like over bits of it and
he's super funny there's this british
dude living in the [ __ ] council of
states that's [ __ ] hilarious his name
is johnny [ __ ] casey yeah [ __ ] casey
[ __ ] he doesn't post that off he doesn't
post his shit's real lo-fi too yeah he's
also an author yeah i keep meaning to
like buy some of his books he hasn't
posted in a long he doesn't post it
regular but he has
10 years worth of [ __ ] videos in the
past he stopped recently
he must be got another job or something
i got bored with it
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] amazing though for
about 10 years he posted [ __ ] really
cool [ __ ] [ __ ] case cinema and his [ __ ]
was mostly it he did horror movies but
he did a lot of action movies mostly
like bad action movies yeah like he'll
he knows all about seagal they'll tell
you everything about sagan he's got all
the dvds
yeah
and he's just kind of just a beer
drinking [ __ ] englishman he's the
kind of english dude that i'd [ __ ]
hang out with [ __ ] badger knows what
i'm talking about he's just crazy he's
just like this bald
drunk
dude with sunglasses
yeah
he's like something off of the young
ones
a little bit yeah not quite as a
caricature but
yeah he's super funny though funny yeah
i wish he would post more often i mean i
know that it's like it's a lot of work
but
this isn't even a song this [ __ ] case
cinema
yeah cause he hangs out with like all
these
he hangs out with this other dude named
professor bruce yeah who's in some of
the videos yeah but somebody and like i
said the videos are like super low-fi
but that's what i like about them it's
just like they're supposed to be they're
so shitty and cheap and it's just like
super super funny they're like they're
like [ __ ] around in the backyard of
their council house or whatever it's
like super funny
but uh yeah i like him but i wish he
would post more often but he doesn't i
think he kind of got
he used to post a lot more often and he
would even do like awards shows like at
the end of the year you know what i mean
like what was the shittiest movie the
shittiest movie and stuff um and he had
like all these
categories like at the oscars yeah but
we sit there we will [ __ ] binge watch
[ __ ] case cinema we would do that [ __ ]
like several days
all his damn video so i'm gonna give a
big shout out to everybody at 13 o'clock
go check out
[ __ ]
not showcase
[ __ ] case
yeah you start and you will understand
it as soon as you see it if you notice
if you like steven seagal you will
understand every bit of this yeah i
think a few months back i mean i think
the last one he put up was a couple
months ago but he did um
i think before that
like the couple videos before that he
did a stephen's ago yeah he's got it
remember he did that steven seagal
vampire movie yeah he's that looked
amazing he's reviewed and by amazing i
mean super super he's reviewed every
stephen seagal movie well a lot of them
yeah like a lot of the direct a lot of
the directives yeah i think he's done
all it looks like he owns them because
he always shows them like so he's got
like a huge collection
which i think is it's hilarious oh my
god it's so [ __ ] funny yeah some of
the movies that he does on there i'm
like i can't even the stephen cigals i'm
like i can't believe that shit's real
yeah i can't believe that shit's real i
can't believe how many movies steven
seagal's made
like the direct-to-video ones that they
never end
and they're and the titles of them are
so generic that it's like
maybe maybe
this is this is just a theory maybe he's
just made like three movies and then
they just keep re-releasing them like
under different generic sounding titles
and no one notices the difference
maybe that's what that is that'd be like
the low effort thing to do
oh
yeah right yeah
well like i said i think you're like a
drink
a drink ahead of you
i think you pushed your wig back too far
now your forehead oh good no
big ass forehead and now i'm like a
klingon warrior
i was just gonna sit now you look like
you're playing god push it back a little
bit farther yeah like a klingon warrior
it's funny how pushing it back like only
in half an inch like
makes you look like a klingon i'm for
real though i'm thinking about [ __ ]
going to [ __ ]
are you really you don't want to
you don't have you don't want to go you
have to go but it almost be kind of fun
i don't know i don't know if i feel like
it but
hopefully christmas time you guys review
that christmas slasher flick to all a
good night from 1980
directed by david hess oh my god i'm
gonna have to do that then i don't think
i've ever seen that movie
now that i'm thinking of david hess was
in [ __ ] um what do you call it uh
last house on the left yeah among other
things
um i don't know i want to go outside
t-r-o-t really yeah we don't have to we
don't have to [ __ ] stay for a whole
long time though jesus it's early it's
early i want to get something to eat i
got all kinds of chicken
well can i can i relax and like finish
my drink and oh yeah
god i got up so early
it's just up the [ __ ] road
and like get a couple drinks and just
yeah but it's easy for a dude you don't
have to like put makeup on again and
you'll like fix hair again you know your
makeup is good it's not it's almost good
no your makeup is good it's been on for
like several hours
you don't understand it gets all like
[ __ ] gummy if it's been on for a few
hours
you know all you have to do is like
throw on a new [ __ ] shirt and pair of
pants i got a whole routine i gotta do
you know what i mean and i haven't even
finished my drink i just started my
drink
holy crap we'll take that drink with us
i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah no i don't i don't think that's a
good idea i remember tom plugging this
guy the show three years ago yeah we're
talking about [ __ ] [ __ ] cinema i
still ch like i
hope springs eternal like every time i
check youtube i'm just going like cuz he
get a new one no yeah does he get a new
one nope is he gonna get notifications i
always check yeah
he's one of the guys i always check i
always check him i always check
uh brandon ten old he he puts
at least one up a week uh i always check
oliver harper i always check dan bell
obviously um i always check company man
company man i think he actually puts up
two a week
his are a little bit shorter like his or
12 to 15 minutes
um but he puts up a couple weeks and
those are good those are they're not
movie reviews those are like about
corporations those are like actually
really interesting
um but those are like the main ones that
i check
and cinemassacre but like i said they
mostly do
video games he doesn't do a lot of
movies
james will do a lot of movies like
during october because of halloween but
other than that it's usually like video
game stuff and i don't play video games
all that much so it's like i don't
really get that much of a [ __ ] about it
just saying
oh are you done
wait a minute
he really wants me to go outside yeah
okay yeah i'm getting ready to go
damn it
he's going to ruin my whole
i'm just hungry i want to get something
to eat what do you what we just ate but
we just stayed before the show started
no you ate i didn't eat
oh i eat before that but about oh well i
was a couple hours before that yeah i
ate at four o'clock remember that
because
you were recording yeah i recorded a
booklet earlier so you know i didn't
disturb you
i didn't even know what you were doing
out there i don't know what you're doing
he just makes food and brings me food
without asking me what it is no i made
the food yesterday okay well i didn't
well i didn't know you're bringing it i
was just making a video i didn't know
that i heard you
oh okay yeah i was recording a book
review
and i was watching a movie
to review for next week okay which is
gonna be
uh in case you guys have seen it we need
to talk about kevin
that's the name of the movie uh based on
the novel
wow that's another movie that made me
glad i don't have kids but you know what
i mean
it's kind of that whole like terrible
evil children genre
yeah dj maniac says
off-the-shelf reviews yeah oh yeah i
forgot about them i like them as well i
like them because it's like it's two
british guys and they'll sit there for
like 40 minutes it's kind of like ours
like they'll sit there for 40 minutes
and like just totally go off on the [ __ ]
um and they do a lot of old horror and
british horror too
so yeah i like that too
oh we put the hat back on
dg maniac says cinemaskar has been
asleep at the wheel lately yeah he
hasn't really posted much but yeah he'll
probably have more content next month
i'm kind of hoping he does more like i i
hope he does monster madness again
because honestly that's
i've rewatched his james did a video a
couple years ago where
he varied dorkly and geekily and i say
that in in a loving fashion
um
was trying to get like the the most
accurate dracula adaptation like the
movie adaptation like the one that was
closest from the book and he had 12
different dracula movies and he went
through this whole long thing where he
compared every single plot point like
from the book to the movies like to see
which one was the most accurate i've
watched that video probably like three
or four times for some reason i just
like i was really into it
you know what i'm saying yeah
all right tom's getting that way yeah
that way
[Laughter]
we don't have that many people in the
stream and [ __ ] i'm getting tired
let's get stuff let's get something to
eat
okay but i don't want to i don't want a
[ __ ] ton to eat though you guys go
i don't have to go where oh no good i
thought you didn't want to go you have
to go no i said i don't want that much
to eat okay i just said that okay
i said this is what happens when you
don't listen to me okay
this is what she does
why are you why are you being this way
why i'm not being this way yeah you are
no why are you being this way i was
having a good time anyway i was having a
good time and now
and now suddenly i'm all stressed out
because like oh [ __ ] now i have to go
someplace
did i have to like change clothes and i
have to do this and yeah it's early but
i know but it's a pain and it's like you
know okay okay
we can go over here i'm starving i'm
starving i'm not though okay i'm not all
right you want to run the show
no it's fine okay cause i'll just go get
something to eat
we've been doing the show for three
hours
i don't we'll see when you say go get
somebody do you mean go to the kitchen
and get something to eat or go out and
get something i'll go to the kitchen
okay i don't know what you're talking
about yeah you don't specify yeah so i
don't know what you're talking about i
thought you made you want to go to like
[ __ ] ihop or something i don't know
what you're talking about no i'll go to
the kitchen and get something to eat
okay do the show we'll go get some to
eat okay like i said much longer you're
gonna do the show no i'm stopping okay
because you want to go somewhere so yeah
so i gotta go i'm gonna do the show for
three hours so i gotta go find some [ __ ]
i know but jenny will sit up here for
six hours she really works i won't yeah
i won't i wasn't gonna do that i just
said when the show was done i was like
wow it would be nice to like get in my
jammies and like
okay you know just like you can do that
no i can't no i can't now because you
want to go out and you're gonna like
blame me if we don't go out
all right guys we're gonna have so i
have to so i have to go all right all
right guys we're gonna forgo and cut
we're gonna cut it loose we're gonna
we're gonna cut it because we'll just go
in circles and [ __ ] keep talking to
me but uh now i'm gonna go find some
clothes like share and subscribe we will
be back uh when now friday friday we'll
be back friday guess what the show is do
you remember what's what's you jimmy
hoffa that's right jimmy hoffman finally
we're finally imagining that
you know everything you you know where
he's at
uh you know yeah i think i do know where
he's at you don't know where he's going
oh we'll talk about it go find his ass
no
no you wouldn't be able to find him
i
i didn't hear a [ __ ] reliable source
through that i think
through uh shows
that i watched that [ __ ] were pretty
well researched
his body was destroyed but we'll talk
about that on the show go ahead
um that should be fun that should be a
function yeah cause it's like it's about
a disappearance but he was also a kind
of a gangster
if the story i heard is true
there would be nothing to find of jimmy
hoffa
he would have been
vaporized that's probably why they never
found him intriguing yeah well i kind of
feel like well you want to go ahead and
spill it no okay don't ruin it all right
we'll talk about that grant there's
hamburgers i know where jimmy hoff is
but i can't talk about it
they keep going where is he buried he's
not buried
well i kind of feel like if you really
wanted to get rid of a person don't bury
them because you can find them later
that [ __ ] sticks around in case you guys
didn't know the mob had access to the
skeletal form the mob had access to a
lot of industrial equipment they knew
how to get rid of a body where there
would be no choice
i'm honestly surprised that doesn't
happen more often they had they had lots
of friends in industry
okay so no there would have been nothing
left if it was true
that kind of sounds like likely and it
was very easy what they were talking
about super easy they're like oh it
makes sense yeah you'd never find him
okay but no i think i know what they did
with him
we'll talk about it on the show
did they did they put him in pies like
in sweeney todd no
i know i know they
don't it had to do with them and it had
to do with industrial waste disposal
we'll get about it we'll talk about it
in the show
that's why all the mob guys you say i'm
in sanitation yeah yeah
they had they had friends everywhere
they had access to technologies that
only industries would have but when i'm
telling you when i tell you what it was
that i had heard what they did with them
you go oh well of course
yeah
and that's what you would do i can
imagine it's not even a big deal
right
all right she went down the wrong pipe
yeah
all right so we'll be back friday night
talking about jimmy hoffa yeah uh you
guys have a good rest of your wednesday
night and have a good thursday
uh i'm gonna put up a review tomorrow
for i don't remember what movie it is
but something
i'll put movie review tomorrow that was
just me
so thanks everybody for dropping by
thanks for super chats thanks for all of
that kind of stuff
and we will see you guys friday night
bye